To to,
to,
to do.
Boom.
Mike Baker.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Boom.
How are you sir?
I'm doing well.
Hey.
You know,
it seems like the year is going well so
far.
Not much to report.
Is that sarcasm?
You guys allowed to use that guy?
No,
I know we're supposed to have that
removed when we joined.
Um,
but uh,
yeah.
No,
it's going good.
Going good.
Thank you families.
Great kids are doing very well.
Business is going very well.
I know everybody was most concerned
about my family and my kids.
Absolutely.
That's how people start off pocket.
Well we just want to hear.
You're having a good time up there in
God's country.
Ah,
yeah.
Idaho,
Idaho.
Beautiful place.
We're just talking about how awesome it
is up there and we're getting a lot of
snow.
I mean you got to get on a ton of snow
up in the north,
particularly here in California,
but we're getting just hammered five
feet up in big bear.
Bear apparently just got covered in
snow,
which is awesome.
We had like 330 inches of snow up where
we've got a place up in about two hours
outside of Boise,
up in the mountains where we go skiing
and fishing and I'm not at the same
time.
That'd be a hell of a sport.
Someone's probably done that.
We know.
I know.
I do know the guys are cross country
skiing into hunting spots now.
Yeah.
That's a thing that guys are doing.
There's actually these foldable skis and
you strapped these things on and they
can stuff in your pack when you're done.
And apparently it's way better than snow
shoes.
So when guys are trying to traverse,
like really unpack like fresh snow,
no path fix stuff.
They're doing cross country skiing.
And I mean,
that's tough.
That's tough work.
But it,
it's,
it's not as tough as snow shoes.
Snow shoeing is,
it is a grind for any distance.
Right?
But,
uh,
but yeah,
you know what you do see,
I mean we were skiing fresh tracks off
off the,
uh,
the side back backside of one of the
mountains that we ski is two weeks ago
and the snow was falling.
There was no wind,
it was just beautiful.
There was nobody we didn't.
I think we saw,
I think we saw two other skiers the
whole time that we were out and it's
just stopped constantly and just stare
and look around and you think how
beautiful it says,
and then I do what everybody does.
I take out my phone to it cause I'm
going to capture the moment on my phone
camera and somehow get the grand of this
scene on my iphone and I always do the
same thing.
I go,
I go back to the sit in the cabinet.
I look at.
I go,
oh,
that's a stupid photo.
Looks like white.
Yeah,
that you.
That's it.
That's the picture you took.
That's one of them is pretty goddamn
beautiful.
Still pretty beautiful.
I have some buddies that live up in
Ketchum.
They run a firstlight.
My friend Ryan Callahan.
Shout out to Ryan Callahan.
He runs a firstlight.
It's a hunting clothing company and
they're up and catch them and he's
always just raving about it.
Yeah,
I catch them straight.
That's where Sun Valley is and it gets
more crowded up there.
You know,
but it's uh,
it's kind of like a high end,
a great town.
It is a fancy fancy pants.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at Idaho,
there's two.
There's two blue spots in Idaho.
One is boise.
They're very democrat,
you know,
heavy city and the other is a catch him,
uh,
in that,
in that particular county because of Sun
Valley being there.
And so we get a lot of,
a lot of wealthy folks,
but it's a beautiful town.
It's a great community.
It's a year round community,
but there's some other towns is a place
up there in Idaho called McCall,
which,
uh,
again,
it's a couple hours outside of Boise,
up in the mountains and it's a real
town,
right?
I mean,
there's nothing fancy about it,
but it's a great place.
Sits right on this beautiful lake,
pay at like and uh,
you know,
fishing is fantastic.
And then the skiing is great during the
winter.
It's,
you know,
I sound like I'm on the Chamber of
Commerce.
Well listen man,
we were saying right before people from
Idaho don't like to talk about how
beautiful Idaho is because they're
trying to keep people out.
I know,
I know I shouldn't do that.
I have some friends that have a house on
quarter lane and they sent me pictures
and you just go,
Holy Shit.
You get to look at that like they're on
this lake.
It's about 100 feet deep and you could
see the ground like it's glass.
You see the bottom of that lake.
You could see the logs that are down
there,
the sticks.
I'm like,
that is crazy.
It's crystal clear wildlife up there.
It's fantastic.
It's just,
yeah,
it is in this place.
Places like that all around the state,
you know,
and,
and the Nice thing about Idaho is,
I mean,
again,
everybody says,
oh,
what if we turn it into the pbs,
Idaho,
our,
it's a,
it gives you a different look everywhere
you go.
Eastern Idaho,
west,
you know,
up north,
it's.
Yeah.
So there's a lot going for it.
And the hunting's great.
The fishing's fantastic.
Fly fishing is amazing.
Whitewater Whitewater is gonna be
insane.
This year because of the snow,
it's good.
It's a great place to be.
The climbing is good and a giant chunk
of that is public land.
Folks.
That's your land and this is something
that I put on my instagram yesterday and
the day before as well because there's a
bill that got introduced that's being
proposed to sell off public lands.
And uh,
there's this one representative.
What's that fellow's name?
They got Jason [inaudible] from Utah.
He introduces bill.
How dare you,
Jason,
to try to sell it.
Look,
as a young fellow,
he doesn't fucking know what he's doing.
Look,
he looks like he's in his thirties.
Just people don't realize how lucky we
have it to have so much of this country.
Public land like that where you can.
And it's not just hunting folks when you
know,
people say,
oh,
we're both living.
No,
listen to me.
You could hike this.
You could fish,
you can camp.
You could just go lie down and stare at
the stars.
It's your land.
This is all ours and it's unprecedented
in this world.
There's no other country that has
anything remotely like our public land
system.
We can't let them give it away.
You can't let them sell it.
And if anybody wants to like,
you know,
uh,
give a kick in the ass to hunting.
I don't understand that either because
you know,
what a lot of the land is maintained by
hunting,
you know,
and,
and you know,
both in the fees and also just the
hunting itself is doing a great service.
You know,
so I,
I don't,
I don't quite get that.
I mean I understand it and I suppose on
an emotive level because how could you
kill that thing?
I think because he's tasty because I
like to eat,
you know,
it's,
I,
I get it.
It's a kind way to go to the R,
m,
e,
f page.
You want to see money for conservation,
for hunting.
You want to see some staggering numbers.
The twitter page,
a Rocky Mountain Elk Federation r,
m,
e,
and they post
these charts that show the billions and
billions of dollars that go towards
conservation every year.
All because of people who fish and hunt.
It's,
it's the numbers are staggering.
You go to Cabela's and you know,
I always wondered about this.
You go to buy something at a Cabela's or
bass pro or wherever you got in your
local area and you know routinely
they're saying,
well,
how would you like to donate a dollar to
conservation fund?
Would you like to donate a dollar to a
course?
You would,
because that's a percentage of your sale
goes directly to it anyway.
If you're hunting equipment,
a certain percentage,
I forget what the number is,
but it's a good healthy percentage.
It turns out to be millions and millions
of dollars every year.
There we go.
Just Minnesota,
look at this.
More people hunt or fish in Minnesota,
one point six,
$5 million than doubled the combined
populations of Minneapolis,
St Paul,
Rochester and Duluth,
and three point one,
$7 billion is the amount spent by 1
million,
649,000
hunters and anglers in a single year in
Minnesota.
That's an incredibly large part of the
economy folks and a giant chunk of that
goes to preserving wildlife habitat to
preserving wetlands to make ensure that
animal populations are kept healthy,
to make sure that Predator populations
are kept in balance and that ranchers
aren't,
you know,
impeded upon by mountain lions and
wolves and shit like that.
That's a,
it's an incredible number.
Yeah.
That's great.
Just for Minnesota,
right?
Yeah.
Jasmine,
you know,
and then you think of the other states
all combining together.
You know,
it's the reason why we have more white
tail deer in America today than when
Columbus landed.
That's a fact.
Support.
We'll get this Michigan $576 million in
state and local tax revenue enough to
support the average salaries of nearly
11,000
police and sheriff's officers.
It's incredible.
I didn't know we could still mentioned
in Columbus.
I didn't know that was allowed.
What's allowed.
We can talk about them.
It's Kinda,
it's kinda crazy.
Columbus Day when you find out what a
savage.
He was like a terrible person.
Columbus was Columbus Day.
What do we have any Stevia,
Jay?
This tastes like shit together.
I'm not.
I'm not a fan of this the way it is with
the butter.
I liked that.
Emulsified mct oil,
but I don't like it blended into.
It's just that I'm expecting the other
kinds of coffee and it comes out like
this.
I'm like,
what is this?
It's all.
It's not the best at what do I know?
I'm going back to the old way.
You know what I'm saying?
We think it's okay.
That's pretty good.
Just a little different.
Tastes sweeter.
Something we need less of it or
something.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just a bitch.
How much do you drink a day?
Let's have coffee.
I don't even count it.
I just keep going.
I really don't.
I'm used to.
I used to worry about it.
He said,
man,
maybe I should back up off the coffee,
but coffee is an excellent source of
antioxidants.
It if you're not,
you're not dehydrated.
If you're drinking plenty of water on
top of that.
I always drink water with it and I don't
see any negative effects when I go get
my health stuff done and get blood work
done so I don't fucking back off at at
all.
Yeah,
but sometimes I do get a little too
jazzed up.
There's this company that we have a
sponsor,
just my friend's company.
Caveman coffee.
Yeah.
And they make these nitros.
They're these little tiny things there.
Nitrogenated coffee that's 270
milligrams of caffeine and one little
can.
Holy Shit.
Get Mr Baker and Baker nitro.
We should show them all these things.
I've got a busy day tomorrow in the
morning.
First thing and these little fuckers.
I take these four,
I lift weights and I want to throw
things through the fucking walls and I
do say so.
Good.
It's so good.
That little tiny thing is 270 milligrams
of caffeine and it's nitrogenated,
which that's fine.
That's good.
Well,
you know I'm going to start.
I'm seriously.
I gotta I gotTa.
I got an early call in the morning.
I got an early start.
A lot of activity going on.
I'm just going to pop this in the
morning.
We'll give you a few of them.
See what you can do.
I'll give them to the team.
Yeah,
good.
That'll be good.
Have you liked the taste of actual
coffee?
It's really good coffee.
It's like there's a whole story behind
the company,
but it's this one farm in Columbia.
Single source,
single family.
It is Columbia.
Right?
Even things that I know for a fact.
I'll say them and I'll go.
Are you sure?
Like right away I question myself.
I think I've got.
I've got to erase some of my data.
I've done that.
I've paired it down.
I'm,
I'm streamlining now thinking of the bar
again,
maybe just a little kick boxing,
sparring.
Just to trim down some of my memories.
Few too many in there.
I might have to take a couple of jabs.
It says my boys,
two of my boys,
actually all three of them.
That,
what am I saying?
All three of them.
Uh,
my,
uh,
my kids,
a scooter and sluggo and mugsy or nine,
five hilarious names and they're
hilarious.
Former CIA operatives,
kids.
But like the three stooges and so they
uh,
but they in,
they're in taekwondo now.
We looked around,
we checked out a few places and we found
this one that we really like.
And then also to be fair,
part of it is just timing.
They,
they,
they're,
they're structuring their classwork or
their timing works well with other
things kids are doing,
but they're in there.
How old are they?
They're nine,
seven and five.
That's a good age to start taekwondo
because then you'll learn the dexterity
and the flexibility and stuff like that.
And if they really get serious about
martial arts,
you can transition them to something
like Jujitsu or kickboxing or something.
But I think,
I think the middle one will stick with
it.
He has is supremely focused.
The only one is does very well,
but he's got a variety of other
interests.
Right?
And right now he sees focused on,
on other sports,
Lacrosse and basketball.
But that,
that middle one,
um,
he,
you could just kind of watch them and
see,
you know,
it's like everything else,
right?
Your kids spark on different things and
he seems to have really sparked on this.
The one,
the five year old,
you know,
he does great,
but he's got a sparked on candy bars and
things like that.
Yeah.
That's one of the fascinating things
about having kids is to realize there's
only so much that you do to shape their
personality.
They come out of the box unique in a
weird way.
Like I have two daughters that are
young.
I was six and an eight and they are so
different.
I mean,
so different.
Six year old thinks farts are hilarious.
She's so funny.
But she'll say,
can I tell you something?
Can I tell you so she just on you and
then she'll fall to the ground laughing.
She's got to meet my five-year-old.
Those still get along like a house on
fire.
Everybody gets mad at her and just can't
do that.
You just can't be farting.
And I'm laughing.
They're like,
don't laugh at her.
I'm like,
that is hilarious.
Just farted on you.
What's the goal?
Is more of a girly girl.
Yeah.
Much more of a girly girl.
Six year olds is savage.
He's like a little gorilla.
She's really hilarious.
She's very,
very funny.
Yeah.
Well my three disbanded.
They spend all their time just like
every other kid,
right?
But boys in particular,
they spend all their time beating the
shit out of each other.
And so we thought,
you know what we've been looking for
awhile to find the right place for them
to channel that physical side of things.
And uh,
and now it's good because now they focus
on,
you know,
if they're gonna,
if they're gonna hurt each other,
they're going to hurt them each other in
the proper way as get some spartan and
get some sports.
One of the good things about Jujitsu,
you know,
we had talked about getting your kids in
Jujitsu.
The good thing about Jujitsu is you can
go full blast.
The thing about kicking each other in
the head is,
boy,
you could really only do that a couple
of times and then,
uh,
yeah,
that's right.
You just not the same person anymore.
That's the reality.
My kids are allowed to kick me and punch
me full blast as long as they tell me
they're going to do it.
So I like let them throw full power leg
kicks because I'm trying to teach them
how to like really sink the Shin into
the meat,
you know.
So like my daughter will throw a left
hook to the body,
right leg kick combination.
She's going to do it right now.
I go,
okay,
go ahead.
It's like boom,
like it's getting harder,
man.
As you get eight and 10 around like 12.
I'm going to have to tell them to stop.
Okay.
That's enough.
Now that is going to have to pat up,
put a chest pat on.
But that's a difference between boys and
girls.
Girls,
you can say you're gonna have to tell
them,
hey,
you can do this,
but you have to tell me.
My guys are like Keto from,
you know,
I walk in the house and they're like
lurking somewhere.
And then the whole goal is to try to
punch me in the junk.
And they think that's hilarious.
With the,
the,
the uh,
the middle one again in the middle one,
he a sluggo he caught me one time when I
came in the door,
the front door of the house and I was
carrying a bag.
I just gotten off a plane carrying it
back and before I could even put the bag
down and sale and the kids were kind of
coming down the stairs,
you know,
I thought it was like a Norman Rockwell
thing,
you know,
they're going to come hug their dad and
adore me a little bit,
you know,
Daddy's home and sluggo comes around the
corner and nowhere and says dad and just
punches me square in the nuts and it was
so hard that I literally,
because you know,
what happens?
I mean,
you know,
you just dropped it.
I dropped and he and the other to stand
there and laugh in my face.
And I thought,
what the end.
My wife is coming around the corner and
she looks.
She goes,
what the hell happened?
I said,
I couldn't,
you know.
How old was he at that time?
He was six.
That's what happens.
So raise a little six year old and the
mountains,
a bunch of wolves and you start punching
you in the Dick as soon as they see you.
That's a larry.
It's Idaho hope rating all do it.
But Jan is out there.
So.
So,
so,
um,
what's your take on this?
Trump versus the intelligence community?
Jazz.
That seems to be going on right now
because I couldn't to get you in here to
get an insider's perspective on this
because I've never seen anything like
it.
I mean I've never seen anything like
what he was talking shit about flu shots
today.
He's like flu shots and the biggest scam
ever.
Like,
are you sure you've done research?
Are you a doctor?
Wow.
Well yeah,
I know that whole and he's.
And he's kind of a point that not
appointed,
but he's brought somebody in as an
advisor on that who is against
vaccinations when that term is and know
that the Intel thing.
There's so many ways you can take this.
It was a.
basically it was a self inflicted wound.
It was unnecessary.
There was no reason for him in the early
stage of this,
when that narrative started to build
about,
oh,
there's this rift building between trump
and the intel community.
It was because of his tweets,
right,
and it was because of him questioning
the,
the intelligence about Russian meddling
in our election system,
and now to talk about that just for a
second,
of course,
the Russians were meddling.
The Russians have been meddling in US
politics and campaigning over here in a
way since they've been around as have
the Chinese,
as have the Chinese.
You could go back to when people should.
This was a fascinating period of time
and in history back to like 1941 go back
to when the Russians were still in an
alliance and a pact with the Nazis,
and so from the Russian perspective,
their goal,
their,
their point was to keep the US out of
the war and so what did they do?
There's an isolation is wing in the
States and Roosevelt was under a lot of
pressure.
Roosevelt was was becoming very close to
Churchill.
He understood that threat.
He was one of the few people that did at
the time he understood how important it
was going to be for America to get into
this battle.
The UK was about ready to fall and so
the British were actually running their
intelligence operations out of New York.
They had a place over in Rockville
Rockefeller Center and because they were
worried they were the island was going
to be run over by the Nazis,
so you have this going on.
The dynamic with the Russians was that
they were still in this packed,
you know,
with the Nazi.
Stalin didn't see this coming and he
didn't see that on the Nazis were
running a very large propaganda
campaign,
a diversion effort to ensure that the
Russians wouldn't know that they will go
about to invade.
So the Russian spent a great deal of
time and money and resource here in the
US influencing us public opinion about
staying out of the war.
There's no reason to be in a boy.
Why would you want to get into another
war in Europe?
And they bought journalists and placed a
newspaper articles.
They paid off journalists.
They were setting up associations that
were supposedly independent,
but we're run by the Soviets.
They were influencing unions,
dumping money into unions and bing
basically to get them to steer their
membership to isolation as you know,
a agenda.
So to say that,
oh,
I don't know if the Russians were men.
Like of course they'd been doing it.
That's the way.
And then all the way through the Cold
War,
you know,
that's,
this is what they do,
so you know,
but it,
it the narrative because it always has
to be simplified.
I think as far as the media is
concerned,
the narrative was that they influenced
the election will.
No,
they were meddling but they weren't
hacking into election systems.
They weren't hacking into voting booths
and changing these things.
So.
So we say meddling.
What they were doing is essentially they
were getting information that was
private that was being distributed
between the Democratic convention.
They were definitely involved in,
in the DNC hacking for instance.
They were definitely involved in how
were they involved with they involve.
Were they,
did they directly did the hacking to the
Democrats or were they privy to.
The information because someone sold it
to them or got it to them,
as with most of these things that
usually those cutouts,
right?
So there's,
there's,
there's a plot,
plausible deniability.
And so,
um,
but the Russians have been very.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No worries.
The Russians have been very.
We
adapt over the years at creating a
mayhem,
creating chaos around democratic
institutions.
Their whole goal is to chip away at
public trust in,
in a democracy and not just here in the
US,
but everywhere.
I mean,
you know,
and obviously that played out in proxy
wars out in Africa.
And so again,
I guess what I'm trying to say is it
should have shocked no one that the
Russians would be engaged in this sort
of thing.
But,
um,
trump,
again,
a self inflicted wound.
He hadn't gotten the full briefings yet.
He hadn't seen the intelligence about
this.
Uh,
and prior to that then he sending out a
handful of tweets saying,
I don't know,
I question.
It didn't make any sense.
You have all the opportunity in the
world to question the intelligence and
the time to do that.
You know,
you're sitting there,
you're getting the briefings from the
heads of the agencies,
which happened,
and then if you,
if you notice after that briefing,
his,
his tone changed completely and he came
out and you know,
okay,
well the Russians were involved,
right?
Um,
and it didn't make it.
Now he had to walk that back.
So then he goes out to the agency and in
any,
as a meeting,
which I think was a great thing,
I was really happy to see that he did
that.
And so soon in the administration he
goes out to,
to our headquarters out out there in
Virginia.
Um,
and you know,
he got sidetracked,
but that's his personality.
He starts talking about the inauguration
numbers.
You start talking about the media,
you know,
the unfair media.
Well,
you know what,
you could just go out there.
Thank you.
People say you're looking forward to
working with them to protect national
security interests,
shake some hands and leave,
but it's not in his nature.
Right?
So he's going to get sidetracked and
it's got to talk about other things.
And then that becomes the story,
you know,
not,
not other things that he's doing,
he's talking about,
uh,
spending more resources on,
on,
on human intelligence,
right?
Because,
and that's something that gets talked
about and is done in cycles.
So after nine slash 11,
what happened?
Well,
suddenly George Tenet,
the director at the time was instructed,
you got to get more officers,
you've got to get more Kadra.
We gotta recruit people.
We can't just rely on signals in
intercepts and,
you know,
technology.
So that happens over a period of time.
He's talking about revamping the Dni or
maybe you know,
taking it apart.
Well,
that's been talked about for many years.
You know,
the Dni was put together after nine
slash 11.
And you know,
it's a big layer of bureaucracy,
frankly.
So some of the things he's told,
what does that stand for?
Dni,
director of national intelligence.
Okay.
So,
uh,
James Clapper was the previous guy going
in there.
I'm a run of that and it's going to be
interesting because the Dni was no,
from Mike Flynn,
who is now the national security guy.
Um,
he had a rocky relationship with,
with the Dni and it feels like they
basically pushed him out of his last
position in the Intel community.
So it'll be interesting to see how he
deals with this issue of,
do we restructure.
But I guess my point being is that,
you know,
and I don't,
I don't really have a dog in the hunt,
you know,
was trump my preferred candidate?
Well,
no,
but now he's the president and we from
my point of view,
now you want it to work now you do
everything possible.
But just like with anybody else,
you look for the good and you say that's
great and if something,
you know,
you don't agree with whether you can say
that too.
We got that right in this country,
you know,
we don't have to agree with every single
thing that any president does.
We can disagree with the policies,
but we don't have to slag people off.
And if I veer off and say,
well,
I don't think a president trump should
have veered off and talked about
inauguration numbers in the media,
what he was standing there in our lobby
in front of the stars on the wall,
you know,
I get,
I get a,
you know,
a couple of hundred tweets,
say,
you know,
you're a fucking idiot.
How could you say that?
Well,
I say it because,
you know,
what,
how,
how is that somehow insulting.
I,
you know,
I'm going to like some of the things
that he does.
I'm not going to like some of the things
he does.
That's the way it works,
right?
You find it.
But I don't know.
I'm very down a rabbit hole right now,
but I think it's because I get,
I'm getting pissed off because,
you know,
we've seem to have gotten away from the
idea that,
you know,
nobody's perfect.
Right?
And everybody that's a,
that's a dyed in the wool trump
supporter right now,
uh,
who for the past eight years,
hated the fact that Obama supporters
were adoring of him and said,
everything he does is brilliant.
Now they're,
you know,
some of those folks doing the same thing
with the new president and,
you know,
like I said,
I,
I'll be honest with you,
I'm happy she didn't win.
I'm ecstatic that Hillary Clinton didn't
win frankly.
Um,
but that doesn't mean that I've got to
now stand up and say everything Donald
Trump does is great.
I wouldn't do that with any troubling
for you about her.
Well,
let's see.
Where do we begin?
Um,
I felt like,
you know,
and again,
I'm obviously,
I'm trying to pick my words carefully
here,
um,
because I'm trying to be diplomatic.
I think she,
I didn't,
I didn't like what I perceived as,
as a,
uh,
a lack of,
of,
uh,
of character.
I didn't like what I perceived as not
again,
and here's the problem.
I didn't like either of the candidates.
Neither candidate was my choice.
Now the candidate was,
I didn't really have a choice.
Now the candidate was my,
I'd have a dog in the hunt,
but if I looked at her,
I just felt like there was,
there wasn't anything there.
And I felt like we had the past eight
years,
I felt like with the previous president
again,
I liked some of the things he did.
I didn't like some of the stuff that he
did,
but I was always concerned that he
didn't have a principles that he stood
on that he said,
you know what,
this is,
this is where I draw the line and this
is what,
these are my principles,
this is what I believe in.
Um,
and I felt like she was similar in that
way.
And I think we've just had enough of
sort of that bend in the wind and do
whatever we're going to do.
This country's lost a lot of leverage
overseas.
And if,
and I know people say,
well,
that's good.
We shouldn't be the police person around
the world.
You know what the fucking truth is?
Somebody has got to be.
And if we're not at the top of the food
chain,
that's fine.
We can step off because we want to build
more roads here and we want to spend our
money here.
And I get that.
And that's important.
But if we're not,
if somebody is not at the top of the
food chain,
somebody else will try or it'll be
chaos.
And what's a vacuum?
And it's not a community of nations that
gathers together and acts in a global
community spirit.
You know,
our,
our interests don't align very often
with other countries.
We have certain allies where it does,
um,
but no,
that's not how it works.
It's chaos out there and it's pretty
nasty at times.
And so I'm a big believer in yes,
we shouldn't be out there policing
everything,
but we're going to need to and we should
want to be at the top of the heap.
Well definitely doesn't seem as any
benevolent superpower that's looking out
for the world's best interests outside
of us know.
And,
uh,
and,
and people raise their eyes,
you know,
when you say something like that.
And I agree with that percent.
People roll their eyes and they go,
I bullshit.
You know,
it's out there and then what?
Right.
We're,
who are they?
Right,
right.
And I know.
Yeah.
And I get those feelings.
I understand where those people are
coming from.
I get this idea of anti-globalization,
I'd get this idea,
you know,
the,
they're,
they're anti the whole idea of the
military industrial complex,
controlling all the resources of the
world.
I get it.
I totally understand,
but know this,
there are some bad countries out there,
not,
not bad people,
but countries that are run by dictators,
countries that are run by extremely
ruthless people and a lot of them have
access to some significant military
power.
Yeah.
And you're absolutely right.
I mean,
a course.
We make mistakes.
Obviously we make mistakes,
but I,
you know,
I spent almost all my life overseas and
I spent a long time peeking behind the
curtain and we see,
we try to self correct.
We may take a wrong turn,
we may do something that,
you know,
okay,
fine that the site doesn't work it out,
but we,
we tend to try to do the things for the
right reason regardless of which
administration it is,
you know.
Um,
and just as,
as a,
as a principle guiding principle,
I,
and maybe people hear that and they
think you don't want a fucking idiot.
You know,
that's not how it works,
but that's how it works.
Um,
to um,
that's everybody has to speak according
to their own experience.
My experience is that most of my
childhood and adult life overseas and
I've seen a lot of weird shit and I've
been to a lot of difficult places and
America stands.
Um,
again,
a few allies.
The Brits,
I'm partial.
I'm a dual citizen,
but the Brits are right there with us.
Uh,
Canadians who doesn't let the Canadians,
um,
New Zealand,
Australia,
you know,
there's a small community there that
tries to be principal,
tries to do the right thing,
uh,
everybody else out there as acting
purely on their own best interest and
our interest and there's almost never
align whether it's Russia or in parts of
Europe or wherever it may be,
Latin America.
Um,
so yeah,
somebody got somebody to be at the top
of the food chain and I just prefer to
be us.
Yeah.
The,
I mean,
there's massive criticisms.
The United States and a lot of them are
valid.
It makes a lot of sense,
but there's human beings are just
flawed.
This is,
this is the most recent country,
this is the newest country,
and this is the only country that exists
like this,
this experiment in self government that
exists today.
There's nothing like it out there and
the more you look into it,
you have a much more intense and deep
understanding of it than I ever will
because of your experience in life and
all the different places that you've
been in,
all the things that you've seen,
but there's no way.
If you look at the rest of the world,
there's nothing.
There's nothing remotely similar to
what's going on over here.
This is a crazy place.
It's a crazy place as far as innovation,
crazy places as far as creativity and
art and film and comedy and music and
just.
There's so much bubbling in this one
part of the world and,
and,
and liberties and freedoms and exactly
what to do.
I made it great.
You know,
like the protest on inauguration day.
Great.
Go Out and protest that.
Don't fucking go blow up a limo to no
fucking chairs through starbucks and
shit like that.
They did a lot of stupid shit and
that's,
you know,
that's a small,
a small group and that's fine and it's
going to happen I suppose,
but you know,
when they,
when they're out there talking about
oppression and being oppressed in
America,
my thought is always the same.
I always think,
you know,
what we should do,
we should reenact a,
the standard
Tori service.
Everybody should have to serve two
years,
whether it's in the military or some
international component where you go
overseas and you spent a little bit of
time in some shit hole and you see,
see
how bad it is and how bad it can be,
but all these people that walk around
here and talk but,
and I get it,
you know,
we could do better with better course.
We can do better in that sense,
in that sense,
but we need perspective.
Right.
That's it.
That's,
I guess what I'm saying,
a balanced perspective.
How did it happen?
Because this was what was confusing to
me.
How did the FBI in and now originally,
eventually the FBI came around to the
CIA's conclusions,
but for a long time the FBI was
disagreeing with the CIA about whether
or not the Russians had anything to do
with hacking the DNC.
Yeah,
the big.
I think the big disagreement was really
over
right.
I mean it was a big part.
It was an evidence based thing that they
didn't see any evidence that the
Russians were involved,
which eventually became clear and now
there was a arrest.
There was an arrest,
an unprecedented arrest a couple of days
ago,
right?
Yeah.
Well I think.
But you also talked about two different
groups,
so the bureau is the FBI as a law
enforcement,
so when they look at something,
they're looking at it from a law
enforcement perspective.
They're looking at gathering sufficient
evidence to prove a case.
Basically that's how they look at the
agencies and Intel operation and so they
are get Gavin pieces of information
that,
you know,
it's not an evidentiary chain thing,
so let's just get the preponderance of
Intel.
Let's see where it leads as some of it's
going to be conflicting,
some of it's not well,
well sourced,
but let's all see what it tells us,
you know,
and so part of it is how they approach a
reaching a conclusion,
but you know,
they were both going to get to the same
place because he eventually there they
sit down and they compare notes.
Uh,
but part of it was the difference of
opinion over the motivation and
motivation is the toughest thing.
One of the toughest things approved in,
in,
uh,
in this business and intelligence,
you know,
that you can say,
okay,
they did this,
but you know,
unless you've got a sore sitting in the
tent,
who was there and part of the
conversation when somebody said,
well,
you know,
this is why,
or this is how we're going to do this
and this is a reason to it without that
sort of sourcing or,
you know,
intercepts,
um,
it's,
it's tough to prove motivation.
So it took a while to kind of get around
to that notion.
And it's still,
to be honest,
you know,
it's still a little bit up in the air,
we're probably never going to get,
unless again,
we get our hands on a really quality
good source,
uh,
that may still be a little bit up in the
air,
but the bottom line is the restaurant
you have,
the Russians were engaged in doing what
they always do,
covert action,
propaganda campaigns,
whatever it may be.
There's the 30,000
foot view was always the same.
They want it,
they want to.
So a sense of,
of,
uh,
of mistrust.
They want to create some chaos.
They want to kind of chip away at the
belief that democracy is a great thing.
And they did look how much time was
spent talking about the integrity of the
election system and whether we actually
had a legitimate president or not.
That's a win.
So you've got a couple of colonels in
the FSB,
which was the old kgb,
who undoubtedly have been promoted as a
result of that operation.
And who got someone got arrested from
the FSB,
who was that guy?
Yeah.
Interested.
I don't have those details in front of
me.
I just did some token guy that pistol
potent exactly when the fucking hall for
Awhile.
He just said the wrong thing,
you know,
but that's unprecedented.
Right.
Then they never have politically arrest
there guys like um,
well they,
they have for certain things,
for corruption issues.
If they get sideways,
you know,
from a internal arguments,
then you'll,
you'll,
yeah.
It usually doesn't make the news because
nobody really gives a shit outside of
Russia and they do now because of this,
because of.
Because people want to talk about it.
And what bothered me about this,
sorry to interrupt you,
but what bothered me about this was the
narrative because the narrative was
Russia hacked the elections.
That's what everybody kept saying and
that's what all these Democrats,
these left wing people were saying to
try to pump up this idea that trump was
not a legitimate president.
Russia hacked
the election.
Russia hacked the election,
will know someone,
maybe Russia,
whoever it was,
put that information out that the DNC
had sent through private emails,
but the information was what they sent
new.
I mean,
it wasn't,
they didn't hack anything.
They didn't get into any election
machines.
They didn't,
they didn't get into the voting
machines.
They didn't do anything other than
release information that was supposed to
be private.
That indicated a bunch of really shady
shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
all those,
all those Bernie Sanders,
how pissed off once you'd be if,
if you're a Bernie sanders supporter and
you're burning himself fucked over.
He got.
Yeah.
Well,
he seemed to have made peace.
I guess he's,
he's a politician that even though he
says he's not,
I mean it,
it's just a weirdly principled one.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
I know Bernie would have been a better
candidate.
I think Bernie would have won a Joe
Biden would have been a better
candidate.
You know,
you always liked the person sitting on
the bench and then they get in the race
and they're not,
you know,
that's true too.
Right?
They might have dug up some shit about
both of those guys,
but Bernie was an interesting guy and
not a whole lot of people that are in
his position for as long as he is that
have the kind of principles he has.
When he was able to say,
you know,
why don't you release the transcripts of
all these different speeches you gave to
all these banks that you got paid a
quarter million dollars and he goes,
I will happily release mine because I
don't have any because I wouldn't take a
penny from those people.
I was on a whole lot of people can say
stuff like that in a big debate and you
know,
they rallied,
they got together and they,
they decided to rig the primaries and
they've rigged it.
They really did.
That was what the Russians exposed,
but it Debbie Wasserman Schultz,
who was a real piece of work,
you know.
Incredible.
Yeah.
So,
so I think there's,
and you're right now,
I guess what obviously what people on
that on,
on the,
on the far left side are saying is well,
but without that,
if they hadn't released that information
then it would have been a different
ballgame.
And you know,
because we wouldn't know how fucking
corrupt she was.
You wouldn't know the Debbie Wasserman
Schultz had done what she'd done and
Debbie Wasserman Schultz wouldn't have
gotten fired from the DNC and then
immediately got hired by Hillary's
campaign.
Yeah,
I mean they picked her up in a couple of
minutes while she obviously they want to
keep her happy.
You know,
when somebody's walking out of that
organization with a chip on their
shoulder talking.
So especially after what she did for
you.
I mean they rigged the primaries.
They really did.
And people should be upset about that
way more than anything else.
This idea that Russia did something when
you expose something that you should,
that we should have known.
We should've known about it because it's
a crime.
You know,
that kind of corruptions essentially.
Collusion.
It's a crime.
It's a conspiracy.
It's a real conspiracy to,
they're,
they're interrupting a democratic
process and that's what they're doing.
Right,
right.
Well that was far more so than an
outside force doing what you expect them
to do anyway,
frankly.
But the Russians did.
They always do.
Yeah.
So I think it would've been a great.
How interesting would those
conversations,
so in,
uh,
in,
in the Kremlin or at FSB headquarters
where they're talking about this and
they're thinking about and they're
planning it.
Someone had to write a note,
right?
Someone had to sit and say,
you know,
I got an idea for an operation and they
had it because they're a bureaucracy
like everything else.
And so they would have had to sit and
figure this out and then it would have
made its way to Putin because,
you know,
this obviously the concern over the
blowback and the publicity of it all.
So Putin clearly knew what was going on,
but again,
that's just the way it works.
Stalin new back in the day knew exactly
what they were doing,
trying to influence public opinion here
back during the early world war one or
two.
So yeah,
I,
there's no surprise the Chinese do the
same thing every,
you know,
every nation that's got the resources.
I mean hell,
we.
Of course we do it too.
People always say,
well,
but wait,
do it.
Well,
yeah,
of course we do it,
you know,
I'm not saying we don't all do it.
It's half of the weird competition
that's going on and you better hope we
do it.
And in a sense,
I always say the,
when people say,
when I talk about,
you know,
a cyber hacking or whatever.
Yeah.
People always go,
yeah,
well you don't have any right to talk to
the US does it as well.
I think.
Well yeah,
that's actually a good thing given how
aggressive and how nasty the world is
out there and how we're constantly being
hit and attacked out in cyberspace.
I mean,
yeah,
we better hope we're good at it.
And you know,
if people knew how often,
how consistently and constantly our
commercial and a public sector
infrastructure is probed and tested and
attacked on a daily basis.
People wouldn't sleep at night.
All the have is watch a showtime series
homeland.
It's super accurate.
That's it.
How you ever watch that show.
I don't watch a lot of those shows.
I'm not a good person to watch shows
like that with my wife.
That's my wife tells me that all the
time.
Yeah.
It's got to be like be watching those.
A karate movies.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Chronic yet of course.
So yeah,
that was legit as fuck.
But like there's some,
like the movie warrior.
I got mad at that movie and I'm like,
you can't fight two days in a row like
that.
They don't.
Although they did do that in Japan
recently.
Crazy assholes.
Japan at a tournament,
I think they fought three days in a row.
Jesus,
it's appendix to the next level.
They don't give a fuck in Japan.
They just go crazy.
They put together this woman,
Gabby Garcia,
she's six foot three,
maybe more.
She might be.
She's at least six to Jesus solid to 40
and they put her in the ring with a 50
year old woman who had bad knees and she
beat the shit out of.
Is that you dinging?
Sorry about that man.
Look at that.
Okay.
Put that thing,
but they put her in with this,
uh,
this woman who is literally 50 years
old,
she's about five feet tall and Gary
Garcia ran over her like a train.
It was,
it was horrible to watch.
They don't care.
Japan will have crazy fights.
They have freak show fights.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
look at all the shows that have come out
of there to be there.
All the,
all the weird shit that ends up on our
tvs usually comes from Japan.
So one of the big arguments was that the
Russians definitely wanted trump to win
because if they didn't then they would
have hacked the RNC and they would have
released their emails too.
But that's a hard argument to make
because you don't know that they said
anything inappropriate.
You don't know
that there was any collusion.
Well,
and there was also a attempts to hack
the RNC and the RNC as would one company
to the next.
Not every company is running the same
security protocols on the
infrastructure.
So the RNC had different security
protocols on their infrastructure and,
you know,
but they were,
they were,
are they not hacked,
but they were tested and the tech,
um,
and you know,
that idea that they wanted,
they wanted trump to win.
Frankly,
if,
if Putin sat there and thought to
himself,
well,
what I want is what's in my,
in Russia's best interest,
well then I'm going to go with a known
quantity.
I'm going to go with Hillary Clinton
because I know what I got there.
And it's not tough.
But trump was like pro Putin and he's
basically saying,
Putin's a smart guy.
Putin's a great guy.
We can do deals together.
We can have.
But he's too smart.
He does.
He's not going to take that on face
value.
I mean he's,
he knows he's reading all the same shit
and watching all the same shit that
everybody else's,
which is that trump is in the past.
It's kind of been all president.
Trump has been all over the place and
talked in different directions.
And so it's not as if potent would here.
They say,
oh,
he likes me.
And he said,
no,
he's not like that.
He's like,
I bet wicker be fresh.
And so it just,
it just a what's best for my best
interests.
It's,
you know,
I'm going to go that route business as
usual,
business as usual,
and I know I'm not going to get any
pushback for the shit that I do because
she is just going to continue the same
things that have been happening.
They're going to continue to withdraw
off the world stage.
And this idea that Somehow Hillary
Clinton was a warmonger,
what the hell that,
where did that come from?
You know,
so I,
I don't,
I'm not necessarily buying the idea that
trump or that a Putin one president
trump to win.
That's an interesting perspective.
I would've thought that he wanted them
to win,
just to throw democracy into the
shitter.
Just to fucking throw a big monkey
wrench into the gears.
He probably felt that a trump victory
would do that.
Yeah.
Right.
And you're right,
there's a possibility there.
But,
you know,
Putin is a,
he's an interesting cat and I just,
I just have a feeling though that,
you know,
again,
they make these,
these,
uh,
these decisions based on what's in their
own best interests and I think they
would look at the track record of Obama.
They would look at her track record,
they would look at an unknown quantity,
you know,
and again,
they're not going to buy what he just
says on the surface.
It's just not gonna,
you know,
it's not that there wouldn't be as
simple as that and they would look and
think,
yeah,
let's go with what we know,
you know,
because we know we can steamroll that,
and this over here,
we don't know now what was.
So what was the point of them meddling
and doing what they did.
Well,
again,
it goes back to the same thing.
They're just trying to create
instability chaos in a,
in a,
uh,
some sort of sense of mistrust of a
democratic institution.
Now,
how much of a factor do you think it is
that Hillary was not ever prosecuted for
deleting all those emails after
subpoena?
Because it seems like that in any other
case,
if you do something like that top secret
clearance,
you're found to have violated it.
He deleted those emails and people are
tired
of hearing about this from the left
though can still bringing that up again,
but I got to think that in light of what
you said about them trying to hack into
the RNC,
but no evidence of they actually gotten
in,
but they did get into the DNC and you
think about all the different security
errors that they've made.
Especially with her having that private
email server and all that shit with homo
was using the same goddamn computer and
printer that Anthony we're sending as
Dick pics out on.
I mean,
Holy Shit,
it's chaos.
Couldn't have written that as a,
as a Sitcom on house of cards,
you would have gone love.
They're going over the top.
That's not believable.
They're jumping the shark.
Yeah.
As opposed to when the secret service
agents slept with the president and his
wife,
you know,
there was that.
What was that?
That was.
I gave it.
That's when I gave up on the series.
Does Not that far yet.
Oh,
son of a bitch.
Dammit.
He was son of a bitch and already won
that.
Can we rewind that goddamn spoilers,
blah,
blah.
Now I'm going to go home and get myself
in the head.
Yeah.
I try to forget that I,
you know what,
I just made that shit up.
It didn't actually appreciate it.
Seasoned.
Who's got it now?
Who's Kinda.
I'm just waiting.
It would have just sitting there waiting
for fucking three service.
Sleeping with a resident wouldn't
happen.
That'd be crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's what he's already done.
Some gay shit.
Yeah.
It's a weird.
It's a weird show.
But that was the point where I said,
okay,
I gotta find myself another program to
watch.
Um,
so.
But yeah,
it's,
um,
that's what,
that's what you were like,
this is unrealistic now.
Yeah.
That's nice that,
that's that bullshit.
That's where I draw the line.
I'm sorry about that.
Somewhere at all,
the presidents that we've had somewhere,
a secret service agent has slipped it
into the missus.
I guarantee you,
I guarantee you somewhere along the line
somebody fucked the president's wife.
I think it was taft.
I think it was the tafts.
Administratively.
They would have done it.
Look,
those are savages.
Back then people were barely human.
Those were cave men with clothes on.
Yeah.
So back shit.
Did you see that one?
A female secret service agent who said
she was a.
She wouldn't take a bullet for the
president.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Well that's your job.
Hooker.
Well,
that's exactly right.
And a fire yet.
Not yet,
but I,
you know,
they,
uh,
I suspect that she will be disciplined
because if you're saying she went on
facebook,
she put it on our facebook profile and
was a good move.
Yeah.
And she supported,
openly supported Hillary Clinton.
Put that on facebook and said that she,
she would not take a bullet for,
for president trump.
And you think,
well,
you know,
you are in the secret service.
That's your job.
Okay,
here it goes.
Outrage at women,
secret service agent and Clinton
supporter,
who said she would not,
capital letters risk her life to protect
president trump.
Secret Service Agent Carrie O'grady
wrote last October that she would rather
go to jail.
Then take a bullet for Donald Trump.
Well,
she definitely get a better job.
Okay.
She.
Oh,
great.
He removed the post days later.
Said she wrote it after being overcome
with emotion following trump's grabbed
them by the pussy video.
Sounds like a music video.
It's like a two live crew music video.
She insists that she would be willing to
do anything to protect the president,
but o'grady has also made numerous other
post criticizing Donald Trump.
Well,
okay.
What's the.
I'm not quite sure I understand the.
The,
the,
the conflict there.
She said she would rather go to jail to
take a bullet for the Donald Trump
president trump,
and then she insisted she would be
willing to do anything to protect the
president.
Well,
now she does.
She removed it and wants to keep her
job.
Secret services that are looking into
the post after a complaint.
That is a dangerous position to take.
If you are a secret service agent.
We're not talking about someone who's a
WHO's a just regular civilian.
You're talking about someone who's Dad
your whole job and you have.
You got to be mean or she's in Denver.
She's,
Geez,
I didn't realize that she's been with
them for quite a while.
Like she knows better.
It's time for.
I would say,
you know what,
that's dishonoring the service,
the secret service and you know what?
Maybe A.
I'm sure they'll,
they'll icer put her in some admin
position,
but you have to in that position,
right?
If you're a secret service agent,
you,
you can't say anything critical like
that publicly about the president.
Absolutely not.
Diminishes the entire position that you
can.
Once you retire,
you could say whatever the fuck you want
without violating any sort of laws that
you've,
you know,
any sort of agreement that you've
signed.
But once you're in there,
that is the job.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like if you were in the agency and
you're overseas and you were campaigning
on behalf of one of the candidates,
it doesn't make any sense.
So I,
I'm,
I'm impressed with her understanding of
social media by posting something like
that on facebook that she was overcome
with emotion though coming to motions
for the outer period will get crazy.
Maybe she had a xanax and a glass of
wine.
She was like,
fuck that orange asshole and just grab
them by the pushy.
How dare you.
Yeah.
What a weird time though that,
that guy actually said that and still
got to let they.
I mean,
that's how much people didn't want
Hillary Clinton to be an office.
I know.
And that's the thing.
And Oh,
by the way,
did you see that,
uh,
that little clip that was making its way
around at the inauguration,
on the inauguration stand of Bill
Clinton checking you out and Allodynia
it,
getting caught.
That was Ivanka.
Ivanka,
his daughter.
So hard.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
God,
Jesus Christ.
Those jeans look was fantastic.
The look was pure Bill Clinton.
He.
Well,
he was like,
fuck it.
It's over.
I don't have to hold it back anymore.
Look at it.
Oh,
good Lord.
Yeah,
he's shaking.
His liquid is a lot.
She turns around and looks at them.
Look at that.
Oh my goodness.
And then it looks,
it gives her a quick look.
Yeah.
Well,
it turned.
Once he looks at her,
he's like,
listen bitch,
you know who I am.
You know,
you live with a wolf that you know you
live with a big old gray wolf.
She's.
Hi everyone.
I'm Ivanka trump.
I wanted to.
I wish you had a fucking accent.
What's going on there?
Oh,
it's her giving them massage.
this is like a porn film that they did a
fake porn about Ivanka trump.
They that.
That quiz is beautiful.
The best part of the inauguration day.
It's over.
I can beat me again.
I'm tired of it all.
That would be the only reason I wanted
or I would have wanted a Hillary Clinton
when the only bright spot I guess I
should say instead of the only bright
spot to her wedding would have been that
he would have been back in the house.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
As a first man on a rampage,
he'd probably be on a rampage.
Watches.
Watches mouth.
Yeah.
Love his mouth.
A little bites.
His lower lip.
He said Ivanka?
No,
he doesn't.
Does he know Ivanka?
Oh yeah.
Look at her.
Look at it.
This is amazing.
Look at her.
Looking at him is fucking amazing.
This.
Look what he looks like.
Adult care.
He shut her down.
One more time.
One more time with the look.
Let me say this again.
Watch this for residential job.
Here we go.
Oh yeah.
It's a mean.
Look.
I bet he gets angry when he was scary.
Yeah.
That was at a highlight.
A highlight of the day.
Whether or not you believe he's killed
people.
He's definitely been responsible for
people dying as president.
That's 100 percent.
I mean,
he's made those decisions.
People have died.
That's in that fucking bed brain of his
and when he looks over at her,
he's looking at her with those that
don't make me kill you with the wolf.
The old grey wolf man.
He would have been awesome and office
again.
Oh,
just roaming the hallways.
You know,
you need his girls and keep your fucking
mouth shut.
Do we have those?
Those uh,
I'm going to need a car.
I got to go into town.
Animal animal.
That guy must've been.
Wow.
What's crazy about him as the stories of
him just pulling his dick out.
Like that's something that people do
like in college when they're drunk.
Yeah.
You know,
you don't do it when you're the
president or former presidents.
Usually you don't.
I mean,
again,
who knows what Andrew Jackson got up to,
but I think,
I think bill took it to a new level.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
I would imagine there was no think about
Jay.
Jay was,
was jfk may have been because who knows,
because he had the benefit of the press
hiding his,
his activity.
They all knew about it and that was a
different time and he was only in office
for how many years?
Three,
three years.
I guess her 63 got killed,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Two and a half years.
Yeah.
Oh,
he would have had us,
what he could have done.
We didn't have back pain.
He was all fucked up and all sorts of
different.
He had some significant health issues,
right?
Yeah.
He was on all sorts of meds and and,
but you know,
he's still managed to find himself
around now and back then they would heal
you with like which doctors,
what kind of fucking medicine do they
have in 1963,
they met us sales.
You should take some of these pills,
Mr.
President,
well,
they would put them on speed to then
they have in mind [inaudible] try to
jazz them up,
but back then I was,
you know,
it's normally get your doctor,
write you a prescription to hear you.
This will,
this will make you feel better.
This throwing Mama's little helper.
Her mother's little helper momma went up
from the south.
Yeah,
it's the position is such a crazy
position.
I mean it's really,
there's no one that's really qualified
to do it and every time someone gets in
it's like,
okay,
let's see what kind of flaws and your
character going to be revealed by this.
And in that case,
when you look at it that way,
at least from the point of view of
representing a stately sort of like,
you know,
like an intelligent,
articulate leader.
Obama did a great job in that regard.
No measured.
That's why the people on the left lobe
and because he,
he,
he was the,
you know,
the projection of the intellect.
He was uh,
you know,
and fine,
and he was,
he was at,
he was in a sort of one of those folks
you look at and go,
that's our president,
you know,
put again,
you could say he did certain things.
Well,
and I would say from a foreign policy
perspective it was not good,
but I,
you know,
you got to be able to say that was good
and there's bad,
you know.
And,
and that's what I'm worried about with
the new president is that I'd like to
think that all those borders aren't just
going to say yeah,
everything he does,
it's good that you still got it,
but they always do that.
Everybody starts on the left.
What am I talking?
I mean here,
what's going on right now with the
Dakota access pipeline where everyone's
blaming trump for this.
They forget this all started while Obama
was in office all over this where they
were putting easements on people's
private land.
When they were arresting these ranchers
for protesting against it,
trying to keep these guys from drilling
into their fucking private land.
That was all during the Obama
administration.
All of it.
I know,
but he gets walking out the door.
I am going to cancel that.
He stopped it and knowing that trump was
going to kickstarter right back up and
he would take the blame.
It's all crazy with the Chelsea manning
commutation and all.
How about Chelsea manning right after he
says that he's a.
A weak leader says Obama's weekly to
pitch.
I just let you out of jail.
Be in jail forever.
You can be in jail for ever.
You could die in jail or in May.
You get to go to a ballgame.
Look at that.
I mean,
I don't think he's gonna want to go,
so she right the Bradley.
It's Chelsea.
She who was formerly known as Brad.
Yeah.
Brad.
Well,
they're not gonna pay for her medication
anymore.
Now that she's really not.
That's a drawback.
I guess she will figure it out.
I think just do a podcast.
The Chelsea Manning,
our Chelsea manning experience.
That's it.
Good?
Yeah.
The death squad network.
Why not?
Why not make some money?
He or she has got to figure out a way to
exactly earn a living.
So she'll be on Fox News on the view
box.
Foxtail is going to bring her in as a
contributor.
I can run on red.
I said,
what the hell?
Come on on side kick show.
Some kind of psychological damage is
being in solitary confinement naked for
like three years.
How,
how bad is that?
Fuck you up?
Because she was in solitary confinement
for a long time and they wouldn't even
give her any clothes.
Well,
I mean I am her,
her,
him and her.
I think originally formerly known as
Brad,
I think probably had some clothes,
probably had some,
you know,
so non suicide watch close.
I think that was the whole deal is that
they kept her naked ladies are saying it
was tantamount to torture.
I'm not buying.
It sounds good though,
right mate?
Yeah.
It sounds good.
But I,
I,
yeah,
it's good.
Episode of homeland.
I'm thinking.
Yeah,
I'm thinking it may not quite that way.
Kept her naked just for a goof.
Mind a picture if you can find a
picture.
It not yet.
Let's wait until we're done with all the
nips and Tucks,
but you're right.
I mean.
Okay.
You know what?
You just got your sentence commuted.
Yeah.
Shut your fucking mouth.
Say thank you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Thank you.
So saying that he's a weak leader,
although there may be some mental issues
here.
I'm just saying maybe that he or she was
not up to snuff or feeling a leveled
out.
Who knows?
It's one of those things and that parent
coast,
most graphic passage of the letter
manage description of how he was placed
on suicide watch for three days from the
18th of January.
I was stripped of all clothing with the
exception of my underwear.
My prescription eyeglasses were taken
away from me and I was forced to sit in
a central blindness.
Oh,
I love your prescription.
I.
It's like if someone took my contacts
away from me,
you know what?
I'd be happy when you're in darkness.
You don't need your glasses,
dude.
Yeah.
He's not in darkness either.
He said it was in total blindness.
Well,
essentially blind from not having a
prescription glasses.
Blind.
Yes,
underwear.
It was three days,
but you see how this happens.
Now suddenly he spends three years naked
and in the dark.
You know the truth is,
again,
I'm not saying this from a right wing,
from the left,
we,
I don't give a fuck,
but the truth tends to always be
somewhere in some defined middle,
the parameter of shift on the middle,
but it also describes the experience of
being stripped naked at night and made
to stand for parade in the nude parade.
Is there a parade for race horses?
A condition that continues to this day
in quotes,
the guard told me to stand at parade
rest.
I don't know what that means.
Parade rest for about three minutes with
my hands behind my back and my leg.
Space,
shoulder width apart.
I stood at parade rest for about three
minutes.
The brig supervisor and the other guards
walk past my cell,
looked at me,
paused for a moment,
and then continue to the next cell.
I was incredibly embarrassed at having
all these people stare at me naked.
I'm embarrassed.
Oh my God.
Embarrassed is torture.
I shouldn't be.
You don't understand that because you
can look at me naked.
I'll just tell you right now.
You want to stare at me and they could
meet without any clothes on if you don't
beat me up.
Okay.
If you're not getting me or torturing me
and you're staring at me naked.
Yeah,
that's my Dick.
What do you want?
Sorry.
There's my butthole.
You want to look?
What the fuck?
Kind of Weirdo or you don't.
You have one too,
don't you?
You want me to look at yours?
I don't want to look at yours.
How about that?
I'm less weird than you.
You know all that talk and would go very
well in the military brigade.
I think you'd probably beat me to death.
Yeah.
But um,
but yeah,
again,
you know,
it's okay.
So you know her,
her sentences commuted and we can,
we can now move on.
She starts her podcasts and then the
question is yeah,
there was a lot of people that thought
he was going to.
Pardon?
Beau Bergdahl,
Sergeant Bergdahl,
fellow who walked into the Taliban camp,
turned himself in,
walked off his post.
Do you remember this guy?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Why?
Why did they think they're going to
wear?
A lot of people thought that Obama was
going to do that as well.
President Obama was going to do that as
well.
Really?
And I thought maybe snowden.
I thought snowden would have been a very
interesting one,
but apparently what he said to meet a
lot of sense was the difference between
when Chelsea Manning did was Chelsea
manning was arrested,
went through trial,
was convicted,
and then he pardoned her.
Commuted her sentence that,
that snowden never face trial and so
because he fled and because he went to
the,
you know,
essentially our enemy to Russia to live
there.
Yeah.
I can't do that.
No,
no,
no.
It doesn't leave when you,
again,
this idea that somehow he kept all the
materials safe from the Russians.
Just it just cracks the Chinese.
He spent time in Hong Kong and I carry
you step foot in,
in Hong Kong or it certainly,
you know,
your cell phone with a one.
You've gotten this idea that somehow,
you know,
Glenn Greenwald,
who is an interesting cat.
I,
I'm not saying he's not,
but Glenn Greenwald and somehow snowed
and we're going to beat the Chinese
intelligence service and the,
and the FSB is a,
might be a bridge too far,
but um,
so you'd have to have some pretty deep
technological innovation to be able to
do that.
I mean,
you'd have to really understand how
those networks work and maybe snowden be
able to protect certain aspects of what
he was talking about.
But I think we have to remember the
also,
he was not lex luther.
I mean it's sort of the narrative got
built up that he was a mastermind at NSA
and high school dropout.
He was an Admin guy and it was an it
admin guy who identified a weakness.
Hey,
fair,
go to him.
He figured out a weakness in the systems
and you know how to manipulate that.
Not that someone can't be a high school
dropout and be bright.
Exactly.
But he was a high school dropout,
I believe that's correct.
I think he got his ged.
He's a.
He was obviously a fucking genius.
He's a super smart kid,
but you know the whole thing.
Yeah,
I think it's very strange.
It's very strange because,
uh,
on one hand,
look,
nobody wants their God damn.
Emails peered into constantly when they
haven't done a damn thing wrong.
Think of a free country.
You think,
well,
Hey,
I'm a freak.
I'm a free man.
Uh,
I have a good job.
I don't,
I pay my taxes.
I don't start any trouble why they
looked at in my email.
So in that sense,
a lot of people felt like they were
vindicated in their fears by this guy
coming out and what snowden.
I get that.
Yeah.
But how did you see it?
Well,
I saw this.
I saw it in more of a simplistic
operational perspective because again,
what we talked about before,
everybody looks at these things from
their own life experiences.
My life experiences are different than
somebody who hasn't done it,
but you know,
you sign up,
you're fucking agreements,
you sign,
you commit yourself to protect national
security.
You commit yourself to treat a
classified material honorably.
So just like the secret service agent,
you know,
when you start making posts on your
facebook,
this is against the whole gig.
You're breaching your agreements and
again,
and,
but people will hear that and they go,
well,
but he was doing a service or,
and then they have the,
they do have this,
this bullshit out there about how he,
he tried,
he tried several times to go and,
and,
and talk about this now.
They never brought it to the New York
Times or Washington Post or any of those
places.
I mean,
internally it was like he's got the
narrative that says,
well,
I talked to my soup,
I tried to get this out there and
everything.
And once again,
the truth is not exactly in either
sides.
Narrative.
Okay,
I'll be,
you know,
so you know,
the,
the far right that goes after him.
It says he should be hanged for treason.
That's bullshit.
No,
he shouldn't,
but you know what I do believe he should
face,
um,
uh,
the court system,
you know,
and I,
and I don't,
you know,
people are gonna disagree with that.
Fine,
fuck it.
But,
you know,
that's what I think,
but the idea of,
you know,
some of the people went histrionics and
said,
you know,
you should be hung.
That's ridiculous.
That's not how we operate.
I also get the idea that people felt
like that was good,
you know,
ultimately that we had that conversation
and I agree with that point because we
should always have those conversations,
but there's a way to do it as a place to
do that as a manner of doing that.
But would we have had that conversation
without him because I don't think we
would.
Well,
I don't disagree necessarily disagree
with that,
but I think that the point,
is it a.
yeah,
you're right.
Where we got what failed us was up on
Capitol Hill where they fail to do what
they're supposed to do.
If they're,
as politicians that we've got there.
There are protocols in place and a
curious public or a curious,
uh,
people's representatives are always
supposed to be having these discussions
about where on the spectrum between
security and civil liberties and
freedom,
you know,
where does that pendulum rest at any
given time?
Um,
these people up on the hill in the Intel
committees,
there's a,
this is a well worn path from NSA,
from the CIA,
from others up to that hill to brief
those people on every fucking thing that
goes on.
I mean,
it just,
this just then people are going to roll
her eyes,
but that's the way it fucking works.
And so then this is also this game it
gets played in Washington where they
pretend like they don't know,
and then they get outraged and they
stand up and say,
well,
I just,
there's almost an angst ridden a horse
shit.
Those people didn't ask,
they didn't pursue,
they didn't ask the questions.
They didn't demand that we have these
discussions internally to.
And so I think,
you know,
politicians in part dropped the ball.
They don't do what they're doing.
The healthiest thing.
We could have a course or people up on
the hill who are constantly questioning
the system,
constantly talking about it because
you're right and it's.
It's very important.
You have to figure out where that goes.
Now another bomb goes off somewhere and
that pendulum's going to swing back to
security.
People go say,
fuck it,
I don't care.
Right?
Check,
check my shoes,
do whatever the hell you want to.
But you know,
read my emails.
Just keep us safe.
And in particular it's a big incident
and God forbid,
but that's where I guess my point being
is that pendulum is constantly moving.
Well,
does that frustrated to frustrate you?
Because that's where the conspiracy
theorists come in.
Whenever something goes on and there's
any sort of a terrorist attack,
conspiracy theorist jump in and say this
is a false flag because they'd been
trying to erode our privacy and erode
our civil liberties and this is the way
they do it.
So instead of looking at it in a broad
perspective,
like looking at it saying,
well,
okay,
is it possible that a terrorist act,
a terrorist act took place,
and now they have to tighten up security
because of that?
No,
no,
no.
People are Matt automatically go to.
No.
They orchestrated the terrorist attack
so that they could tighten up security
because it's this overall global plan to
turn this off.
One world government government.
Yeah.
Well,
I hope I get to be in charge of that one
world government.
That's all I could say.
I would make a hell of a one world
government leader.
So how would you,
how would you do things differently?
No,
I would.
I'm just kidding.
I would hate to be in charge of one
world.
Could you imagine what a goat rope that
would be.
I wouldn't even want to be a mayor.
Yeah.
Being a mayor of the town,
a town of 10,000
people.
You're gonna have 4,000
to fucking hate you.
Yeah.
Retail politics.
I think of the worst,
you know,
local politics and you see,
hey look,
we're talking about Idaho again.
And was like,
oh,
for fuck's sake.
But in Idaho as an example,
I can walk down a street in Boise and
bumped into the governor,
Lieutenant Governor,
we have a nice chat.
They're great guys,
great people,
ranchers,
and you know,
they do this.
And in Idaho they do a,
there was a point to that story.
I'll get it to a second.
But they have the legislature,
just an office for three months.
They,
they do all the work they need to do
with.
They get back to that damn jobs,
right?
Insurance broker,
car guy,
a guy,
a rancher,
whatever it is.
So it's Kinda the way it should be,
right?
You don't need people governing you 12
months of the fucking year doesn't.
It's not necessary.
Um,
but,
uh,
the piracy,
I forgot the point of the story,
but anyway,
you've got this environment where you
can watch the local politics.
That's the point of the story.
And you can see the congress because I'm
on the flights with them all the time.
And the senator,
Senator Rich,
great guy,
he's on the Intel Committee.
Brilliant guy.
But you,
you,
you see what they have to do to stay in,
in office,
you know,
that it,
particularly the congressmen,
they're always campaigning there always
raising funds.
They're always politicking it just.
And you think that it's pretty fucked
up,
you know,
and so that's why I'm,
I'm a big fan of term limits and a big
fan of saying,
you know what,
this does nothing set in stone that says
our congressman congresswoman have to be
just two year terms.
Right?
We did that in the old days because
nobody wanted to be in dc because it was
a swamp and they had to get back to
their farms and actually earn a living.
So stretch that out to four years.
So you can be a congressman for a total
of eight years.
You get two terms.
You could be a senator for terms six
years each and then get the hell out.
Go back to your jobs,
do something else.
And I think we would do,
we would deepen the pool of potential
candidates.
We would see other people come up,
rise up.
It would take some of the money out of
it.
Maybe take a little bit of the influence
on some of the influence out of it yet
if I know somebody going to be in office
and you know,
on the ways and means committee for 36
years,
I'm going to invest a lot of effort and
time and that individual if I'm a
lobbying firm and on k street in DC,
um,
but if I don't,
if that person's not going to be there,
I'm going to share.
I'll figure out how to work the system,
I'm sure.
But I'm gonna it's gonna.
It's Kinda at least shake it up a little
bit and I think it would take some of
that money and influence out.
But,
uh,
I don't know where I was going with that
story.
That was pretty boring.
No,
no.
You were just comparing another million.
The difference between local politics
where people have an actual job on top
of being a local politician.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
it's,
it's a dirty business.
As soon as you're in the business of
governing people,
you're in the business of controlling
people here in the business of trying to
pass laws that help the people that put
you in power in the first place and it
just gets you real squirrely.
It's a little dodgy.
How about that dose ea on,
on President trump,
but what I would say that came out that
was supposedly,
you know who did it that buzzfeed,
that the Buzzfeed,
I think they were the ones who printed
it.
Just recent.
It's a recent one that,
you know,
the Russian was supposedly that he was
gauged and shenanigans with that stuff.
The pen on the bed stuff that's,
you know,
it was ridiculous about that.
Was that major news sources reporting
that as an unsubstantiated rumor.
Yeah.
Like you can't do that.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
That,
that,
that had been out and circulating and
then how could they possibly entertain
that when they know when the times and
you can pick up the New York Times on
any given day and they've got a front
page above the fold story that's relying
almost exclusively on anonymous sources.
Just insane.
So I,
you know,
I don't think,
but it was,
it was amazing that they would run with
that and it was a complete bullshit
report.
It's such a hatchet job hatch.
I mean,
it's like,
it's like a hack wrote it.
I mean,
Lose Good and Hookers to pee on him.
Yeah.
Well come on.
It's supposedly the narrative became
then for those that would like to have
believed that it became,
well the person that wrote it as a very
distinguished former mys six officer
from a British secret service and they
had no,
not currently.
Um,
it was just.
No,
no.
The world of the world of political
opposition research,
this shouldn't surprise anybody is,
it's populated by a lot of sketchy
dudes.
Um,
and no way.
Yeah,
I know.
I know somebody should do a series about
it,
but,
but real,
real,
uh,
but anyway,
so yeah,
that was a,
that was a fascinating little glitch in
the old,
uh,
on the radar.
But I don't know,
it just seemed so strange and,
excuse me,
one of the strangest parts was his
response to it.
Everybody knows I'm a Germaphobe.
It's like what's like,
and it's like I tell all my people,
when you go to Russia,
they're filming anything,
don't do anything stupid,
don't screw around,
don't get paid on.
Do you really think I would just have
people peeing on me?
Yeah,
I mean he's got a point there.
I mean,
it is ridiculous.
I agree with it from as a tidy person.
I'm a beating on.
My wife would say I'm a very tidy
person.
I,
you know,
my first thought would be,
oh,
who the fuck is going to change these
sheets and all this.
Now we've got a carpet and what the
hell?
Yeah.
It depends on how much they've had to
drink obviously.
Oh,
you know what if they've eaten
asparagus,
who's into the WHO's into that?
That's what I really want to know.
Yeah.
And what happened?
What it's usually I've talked to girls
who are dominatrixes and uh,
one of the things they tell you,
it's always these guys that are like big
time ceos.
They run corporations with power type
A's.
You know,
that they want to take them up and shit
on their head.
That's what it is.
Well,
when you describe it that way I can see
what the attraction is.
You know,
I get it.
Yeah,
I,
it's,
it was,
but it was again,
because that got out there completely
unsubstantiated.
But it became that narrative.
Right?
And people would start talking about
him.
I said,
let me tell you about it.
I overheard a conversation today.
Hopefully these people that I overheard
or you know,
I hope they are listening.
I was at the hotel I'm staying at while
I'm in town and I was staying at the bar
and a cup of coffee to go this early
this morning.
And there were two fellows sitting at a
couple of chairs and they were talking
about the new administration and you
could tell they were seriously angst
written about the whole thing.
They were hyperventilate,
very upset about it.
And uh,
one of them said,
well,
I tell you what I'm worried about.
I'm worried about this whole Muslim ban
thing.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
returning to the days of being a white
supremacist nation,
my budget,
both these guys were white and the other
guy goes,
doesn't even blink at night,
doesn't even question what this guy has
just said.
I think it goes,
I'll tell you what I'm worried about.
I'm worried about him signing an
agreement with Russia and in next thing
you know,
they go to war together and in the
Middle East,
not just one country,
the Middle East to get their hands on
all that oil.
And the other guy says in response to
that says that's already happening.
And they were serious and this is what
happens.
Right?
And I'm of these guys.
Well,
you don't have to tell them they were in
a hotel lobby.
They were,
well they weren't,
they look,
so you don't know who these guys were.
I don't know who they were,
but they were dressed what?
Distinguished,
distinguished yell mid thirties
probably.
Uh,
and they really believed what they were
saying.
Oh my.
Well,
they were reinforcing each other.
And I'm not saying it doesn't happen on
the other side.
Of course it happens.
On the other side too,
you know,
but that's the point is it's we've been
people fucking going crazy.
They're losing their minds and it's not
just now with,
with president trump,
obviously the people on the right that
we're doing the same thing with the
previous,
a previous president,
but I didn't know I wanted to turn
around and say something to them and at
least just say,
excuse me,
like do you think you've maybe over
there I was having dinner.
Not that I.
not that I sit in and eavesdrop on
people.
This is your move this,
this is my thing.
Intelligence Agency collects data.
Just go,
you know,
it tends to be,
I'm at dinner in New York last week and
there was a table next to me and I would
just sit in there.
I was waiting for my colleagues to show
up,
so I was,
I'm going to drink.
And I was listening to the conversation
and they were again sort of feeding each
other about,
you know,
apocalyptic results from the election.
And one of them said this is the worst
thing.
And he was absolutely serious and these
guys were probably in their early
sixties and dress very well.
You could tell they were,
you know,
and their wives are with them and then
socializing one percent group and one of
them says this is the worst thing that's
ever happened to this country.
And that actually did make me then
interrupt,
which is ruined admittedly.
But I said,
look,
I hope you don't mind me.
You know,
I overheard what you said.
Does that include nine slash 11?
Does it include Pearl Harbor doesn't
include the assassination of Lincoln.
It's an include the great depression,
you know,
how,
how do you define worst thing to ever
happen to our country?
And I know the guy looked at me like,
you know,
I was a Douche bag and I was,
at least it's all,
at least you recognized what he was
dealing with.
What I said I,
you know,
again,
I'll go back to my drink and I,
you know,
but I just,
I would just curious.
And you know,
there was no give and take.
There was no,
you know,
I didn't get some magical
responsibility.
I guess I was big over the top a little
bit,
you know,
but no,
that didn't happen.
No,
they just went back to them so I don't
know.
Yeah,
we should all just chill the fuck out a
little bit.
Well,
people get on their team and they stick
with it.
Whether it's team left or team right in,
which is why all those people that are
anti war refused to go crazy about Obama
and the drones.
Yes.
You look at all the drone deaths that
happened during the Obama administration
and what percentage of them were
innocent civilians.
It's pretty staggering,
but you don't hear about that from the
left.
All you hear about it from the left is
that the right is a bunch of warmongers.
They're doing terrible things and they
look terrible.
Things are done right there.
Just that's how.
That's how the world operates.
It would be nice if we didn't do
terrible things.
Yes,
it would be.
It would be nice if there weren't places
in the world that were horrific right
now.
All I could think of us.
So with that,
what would I do for a living?
What's my.
What's my revenue stream at that point?
But when I complain about,
yeah,
what do you think about what's going on
right now in Israel?
Well,
that's pretty significant,
but it's no explain to people what's
happening.
Well,
I mean at the 30,000
foot level of sort of,
not to have to start from a different
direction,
but it's a 30,000
foot level.
We,
uh,
we've lost a,
a significant amount of leverage in the
Middle East.
So as an example,
when previous secretary Kerry from
President Obama's administration talked
about,
uh,
going to a conference to talk about
peace in Syria.
It's a joke.
It's ridiculous.
We don't have any influence in there
where they were not the player out there
anymore.
We're not,
because again,
this idea that we're going to step off
the world stage a little bit as we did
that over the past several years,
uh,
Iran in particular has realized more
influence,
more leverage in that region than
they've had in modern times.
And they're ecstatic.
They're,
they can't believe their good fortune.
Um,
and you know,
I'm not just beating on that whole
ridiculous a nuclear agreement that we
ended up signing,
which if secretary Kerry was telling the
truth and saying that it was all based
on verification,
we're kind of fucked because I'm here to
tell you we don't have really good
verification on their programs.
We and we haven't had it for a long
time,
so we rely on the Israelis to a great
deal on some of our couple of our other
allies out there who have better human
source intelligence.
Uh,
but if it was down to us,
you know,
we'd be flying a little bit blind
because it's up to,
it's a tough,
tough target.
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
point being,
as the Iranians saw an opening over the
past few years,
uh,
to do what they wanted to do for a long
time and now they have,
um,
a increasingly tight relationship with
Iraq of all places.
The Russians saw the same thing that the
Iranian saw in the Middle East and,
and,
and we'll get to Israel in second,
but Israel is just kind of sitting
there,
right?
Like Fort Apache.
The Bronx,
so Israel is sitting there,
you know,
we,
they are questioning whether we've got
the same sort of commitment to them over
the past few years.
Russia sees the same thing,
the Iranian see,
so Russia goes in and they start doing
what?
Well,
they start,
they've,
they've signed weapons agreements,
arms agreements with a rock of all
places,
right?
Iraq rock.
They're selling hardware,
uh,
to the Iraqis after everything we were
doing and all the blood and,
and,
and so,
um,
and then they,
they've done the same thing with,
with Egypt.
They've signed weapons agreements,
significant weapons agreements with
Egypt.
They haven't had a relationship with
Egypt since the,
since the Nassar days going all the way
back.
And increasingly,
you know,
obviously the Russians,
they were never ever going to give up
on,
on what they had in Syria.
They've got a,
they've got one port for their Black Sea
Fleet.
That's it.
And it's in Syria.
They're not going to the idea that we
were going to work together.
This is one of those fallacies again
where you think,
well,
maybe,
you know,
our interests are aligned as far as
fighting isis.
No,
they're fucking not that they,
they are not at all.
And so the idea that somehow we were
going to,
you know,
work,
and that Russia had the same sort of
agenda of Russia was never,
never gonna let Assad go unless they had
a rock solid replacement who was on
their team.
So they've created this alliance.
A Turkey in the meantime is kind of slid
in there as well with that st packed
again because we kind of stepped off the
stage and people were curious and when
people are not curious,
but people confused,
where does America stand,
where are we,
what are our commitments?
And when we don't say it out loud where
we don't prove it,
then they start looking elsewhere.
So Germany and Turkey start creating an
alliance,
uh,
the UK and China,
you know,
create economic alliances.
Um,
you know,
France and Russia working together and
again in counter terrorism,
you start getting these weird alliances
that have been built up over now the
past recent few years and then we're
surprised that somehow the European
Union is kind of coming apart a little
bit at the fabric.
Um,
and so anyway,
but the point being is then Israel
sitting there,
fort Apache,
the bronx,
the Bronx,
um,
obviously Netanyahu and President Obama,
not exactly the tightest of
relationships and you know,
they,
they don't have a lot of options.
It's not like they could look around and
say,
well,
we'll align ourselves with somebody else
to protect our,
what is obviously an existential threat
for them.
Um,
they don't have a lot of options.
It's pretty much us.
And so that kind of creates the
environment that we currently existed.
Now obviously there's a feeling that
there's a bit of a sea change and that
the US has recommitting itself to,
to Israel,
to its alliance.
Look,
it's the only democracy,
legitimate democracy out there.
And,
you know,
um,
again,
like with any alliance,
we should always be able to question and
everything,
but we should understand that we've got
to make these things as tight so that
there's no visible daylight between us
and our,
our key allies that others because
they're always looking for that day
light that others could play off of and,
and,
and look to take advantage of.
So that's a,
that's a 30,000
foot look at,
um,
at the region.
It's very disconcerting.
There are six going on,
seven failed states in the Middle East
right now.
And every one of those poses in a sense
of threat to Israel because what are
they,
the Libya,
Iraq,
Afghanistan,
Yemen,
Somalia has obviously done.
And when you say by failed states for,
for the uninitiated,
what you mean is they essentially don't
have a real government.
There's no real government.
Yeah,
there's no,
there's no sense of control.
We're talking about millions of people,
which,
oh yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And I mean,
Libya,
it doesn't get much in the press,
um,
because the previous administration had
no interest in talking about it because
they had pushed for,
for the regime change in Libya.
And um,
that was,
that was a disaster we had again,
let's re.
Yeah,
I don't want to re litigate Iraq or
Afghanistan or anything else.
Frankly,
I think it was a drastic mistake,
but it goes back to what you were saying
earlier in revenue.
Sorry,
what you were saying earlier was that
these,
this idea that we shouldn't be involved
in policing the world.
The real problem with that is when you
pull back,
you create this vacuum.
When you remove leaders,
as brutal as they are,
you create a vacuum.
Yeah.
You know,
when it was horrible,
Saddam Hussein is,
there was,
it was almost better for those people
when that guy was in power then having
what's going on right now,
which is essentially.
I mean it's,
it sounds horrible to say so horrible to
say something like that.
But in the same with Libya,
same with Libya.
Absolutely.
And the funny,
not funny,
it's terrible.
Say that that way.
But the strange thing about Libya was
Gaddafi was working on our behalf in the
world of counter terrorism for several
years leading up to his being removed,
the only folks that,
that were involved in that exercise,
that really had national interests in
Libya where the French and the Italians
and they somehow convinced the previous
administration to get involved and that
it was a good idea.
Um,
and now I mean like Libya has got what,
a hundred and 30 some odd tribes.
It's even worse than a rock concert in
sense of sort of a fractured tribal
environment.
And uh,
it's,
uh,
it's a disaster.
So what I mean by each failed stake
potentially poses a threat to Israel is
that what you get is you get the sucking
a sound as,
as all the air leaves the country.
And uh,
it becomes chaos.
And Chaos is where a group like the
Islamic state or al Qaeda or vocal
Harambe,
that's where the extremists make their
money.
That's where they make their hay.
So they're,
they gravitate to places like that.
It's,
it's,
it's guaranteed.
And you know,
so I don't know how,
I'm just way above my pay grade when you
talk about,
well,
what does president trump do now with
the Middle East?
Well,
he,
he met with Madison,
he met with a bunch of folks over the
Pentagon today and one of the things he
said is,
you know,
uh,
we're going to take action and destroy
Islamic state.
Well,
good luck with that.
You know,
that's one of those things where it's a
nice sound bite,
but nobody should actually think that if
we somehow rid Iraq and Syria,
the Islamic state,
that we've solved the problem and
creating another vacuum.
Yeah.
And then someone else would come in and
fill it.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do you take a place like that and
turn it into a democracy?
That's the real question,
right?
Yeah.
I don't think you'd do it too much.
Deeply ingrained behavior.
Yeah.
Let me think about what it took for our,
for our nation,
right?
I think,
and we kind of want to every.
We got short attention span,
so we just want everything to happen in
an accelerated fashion.
We had to leave.
We're going to have all democracy in
Iraq or something.
They,
Afghans still don't have a clue what we
were trying to sell them.
They don't have a fucking clue.
And a guy that worked for me when I
started the business of business,
been up and running for about a year and
I had,
I had a Russian,
uh,
working on staff,
a very interesting cat was a former,
a gru,
military intelligence,
and it had been a tank driver and he had
been out in Afghanistan during the
Soviet occupation,
uh,
was still carrying some,
some shrapnel around for that.
And when we went into Tora Bora,
he,
uh,
I remember he came up to me,
it was visibly shaken and he said that
was brilliant,
really brilliant,
but don't stay sister,
like cockroaches,
step on them over here and they come up
over here and you fucking step on it.
And he was really literally,
you can tell this guy just was,
you know,
he was,
he was starting to go off and he was
absolutely correct.
We should have gone in there and did our
tactical mission,
which were very,
very good at.
And then left,
but we were feeling the pangs of guilt
from having left previously after we had
that operation to get the Soviets out of
there.
And by the way,
you know,
I,
I'm one of those who are happy to admit
that maybe if you sell shoulder fired
weapons systems to,
you know,
a bunch of folks in Afghanistan at some
point it's going to have to be a bad
idea.
So you have to go back and buy him back.
Yeah,
that was a piece of work.
But Anyway,
point being is we should have left at
that point.
But we were feeling guilty about having
left before and the idea was like,
Oh,
if we just stayed than al Qaeda wouldn't
have found a home base in Afghanistan.
And who knows what we might've prevented
and the honest to God's truth as they
able to found a home base someplace
else.
And we would have just been sitting
in Afghanistan for another 25 years.
Right.
The leading up to now.
So anyway.
Um,
I think that's one of the most
frustrating things about international
conflict when,
when people start thinking about it,
especially people like me that have
nothing to do with it.
You look on the outside and you go,
how does this ever get resolved?
How does this ever get fit?
Does it ever get fixed?
I mean,
is it even possible?
I don't think.
I mean,
it's not going to end.
when I say it,
I guess I'm referring to Muslim
extremism,
jihadism,
whatever you wanna call it.
Um,
now it's not in our lifetime.
No,
not in our lifetimes.
And it's got to be on several levels.
So I'm not saying,
you know,
there's that old saying you can't kill
your way out of it,
but you know,
it doesn't mean you can't make a good
faith effort and that,
but at the same time,
but you have to work at,
on other levels,
right?
You have to do,
it's a meme right there.
We can,
we just remove that as well as my
spoiler on the house of cards.
Who would have imagined that shows up 20
years old,
I would've thought you'd seen,
goddammit.
I just started a couple of months ago.
I'm only on season two anyway with the
uh,
the.
Yeah,
so the,
the um,
I forget where I was going with that
weed killing your way out.
Oh yeah.
But you have to work on other levels
too.
So you've got to fill.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
You got to work with community.
So like we got to.
It's a huge lift and the local and the
state and the federal authorities here
in the US are actually spending a lot of
time trying to build some level of
communication and trust with the Muslim
communities here in this country because
at the end of the day,
uh,
if you just want to talk about somebody
popping off and doing something horrible
here in our country,
again,
the old concept of the lone wolf attack,
whatever you want to call it,
um,
your real only chance of identifying
that individual because they're not
coming up on comms and they're not,
you know,
it's not on the radar already.
They're not associating unless they do.
Maybe they do,
but usually they're not associating with
known targets and so your best bet is a
mom or dad or a brother or sister
picking up the phone and saying,
I'm worried about,
uh,
you know,
whomever,
and I think that's probably more likely
to happen now after San Bernardino when
that San Bernardino attack and there was
a lot of people that knew those folks
were really into guns and St Louis a
bunch of crazy shit,
but they just wouldn't let me just get
outta here and nothing's going to happen
from this.
Let me just leave these fucking ruins
alone.
And then they wound up,
you know,
because I also don't want to beat your
folks,
although,
you know,
a wonderful new word.
Now I'm a fit.
They also use to people who have left
Islam,
which is hilarious.
Really high end.
Hirsi Ali,
they call her Islamophobe.
Yeah.
I didn't know she had female genital
mutilation when she was a baby.
They cut her clitoris off.
She's lived under that oppressive
regime.
She risked her life to get outta there
should we risked her life to come to the
United States and they still call her
and Islamophobia for anyone that said,
I mean,
this is like,
it's fashionable.
Anyone says anything critical about
Islam by becoming an Islamophobia or a
bigot,
you're a bigot.
And then it's like,
yeah,
you're.
Yeah.
Somehow it's
A.
Yeah.
I'm not even sure how we got to that
point.
But um,
well it's the left,
you know,
people go,
I mean,
it's just like the far left gets nutty.
The far right gets nutty,
far reaches of any ideologies.
They all,
you know,
they,
they're blinded,
you're blinded by their beliefs and they
are supported by other people who were
equally blinded.
And you're,
you're right on the far edges is where
the zealots tend to reside for either
side.
And so the friend fringe.
Yeah,
I think we just came up with that.
I think we can develop that theory
really have been around for a while.
Yeah.
You're learning a lot of new stuff here
folks.
Um,
but it's when you,
when you talk,
when you have this,
you know,
you have a,
a,
just a massive amount of experience when
it comes to foreign relations and when
you're talking about the almost like
hopelessness of creating peace on earth,
you know,
like that,
that concept has always been.
Everyone's always wanted peace on earth.
We all want,
right?
But when you talk about the Middle East
and he talk about a hopeless that is,
and then you go back to like the fucking
Carter administration,
you go back previous to that.
I mean it seems like it's always been a
mess.
Yeah.
No.
And it's,
you know,
when you look at,
when you look at the relations that
these countries have amongst themselves,
it's pretty fucked up.
And then you think about,
you know,
our relationship,
our efforts with them and that's a whole
different level.
But there's,
there's a,
I don't want to say it's,
it's never possible that's too
pessimistic,
but from a pragmatic point of view,
I think we just have to be realistic in
our foreign policy and we have to do
what we can to create allies to do,
do our best,
always acting in our own best interest
and just get away from this concept that
we're somehow,
it's a community of nations all working
together for the good of the world.
Um,
some groups do,
like I said,
you can have your allies and that's a
great thing and we should always look to
promote that.
And uh,
but you know,
ultimately I think we're the only nation
sometimes it seems that apologizes when
we act in our own best interest,
we almost feel like it's unseemly or
it's not the right thing to do,
or Jesus or whatever.
That's bullshit.
Every other nation out there,
including our allies at closeouts,
they look at it first and foremost,
how does this benefit me?
How does this benefit our country?
And if you just assume that's a
principle in dealing in foreign policy,
and then you also assume that another
principle is that nothing is
unconnected,
you know,
everything's,
nothing happens in a bubble.
Then with those two things as guiding
principles,
you gotta start to creating a foreign
policy that makes some sense,
you know,
and is beneficial.
Again,
the,
you know,
the difficulty is in,
at what point do you exert your
influence?
At what point do you decide to be the
police person,
you know,
but
it's not just evidence placement.
The good man I conversation about
Bradley team.
You've met Chelsea if you turned it
around,
but don't you think that that's evidence
of the fact that,
oh,
it's because of the fact that we are
essentially the premier superpower in
the world.
And there's.
Everyone else is a very distant second.
So it's Kinda like where the big boss we
kind of have to go,
well,
you know,
we probably shouldn't be doing that.
And yeah,
it is tough because you,
again,
I agree with those people to say we
can't be policing everywhere.
You're talking about China and it's a
good industry.
It's a.
When you say were the lone superpower,
you know,
some people would say,
well,
what about China?
And uh oh,
it just said it.
Like president trump does China.
Then part of China's problem is,
well they've got several,
but one is that their economy,
you.
This idea that somehow they were going
to rise to the top of the heap in the
world because of their economy I think
has always been flawed.
There's a lot of.
We spend a lot of.
My company spends a fair amount of time
looking at Chinese companies on behalf
of financial institutions and others
from outside of China.
There's a lot of smoke and mirrors,
a lot of bad paper.
They're floating around.
They've got some problems,
really shaky problems in their
infrastructure and their economy and
tied to that as a problem that if they
can't manage the slow down if they can
and if they can't manage and it's not
good for us either,
so we have to hope that they do.
But if they can't manage a slowdown and
part of that is in their economy and
part of that is,
is managing or putting a damper on
people's expectations,
you know,
they've kind of gotten away for some
time now with people thinking,
I'm rising up,
I'm coming up out of the poverty class,
I'm getting up to the middleclass.
I can be real close.
Well,
there's only so far in that economy,
they're going to go and they've hit that
ceiling basically.
So they've got it.
There's a lot of discontent in a sense
and a lot of,
a lot of problems that they're,
they're trying right now to mask.
I don't know whether they're gonna be
able to do it,
but we should all hope that,
that they're somewhat successful.
Since again,
nothing happens in a bubble and we're
connected.
So if they have significant problems,
so you can be issues.
But um,
and so I've never been,
you know,
when people say,
well,
what about trying to try and sort of a
rising superpower along with us?
Well,
yeah,
militarily,
I mean it,
you know,
but we're still way ahead.
We're still well ahead.
They're doing it like a mutually assured
destruction ahead thing.
I mean,
we were all fucked if we go to war.
I mean if we really have a world war
that involves nuclear weapons,
the whole planet.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Except for right.
Come on up.
So it's kind of weird though that it's
like,
that mean we are the big super power as
long as none of these people like are
ran or Pakistan or anybody who has
nuclear weapons,
as long as they don't launch anything,
as soon as they launched everything,
we're all fucked.
So we gotta kind of keep everybody from
launching everything.
Well,
and that's really what,
where the crisis is.
The crisis isn't with us and Russia
going to war us in China going to war,
is that the crisis is,
is,
is a smaller a nation with a nuclear
weapons.
I'm losing it's shit for doing something
stupid or some of those materials
falling into the wrong hands.
Those two scenarios are still the ones
that are most worrisome.
When you look at a country like,
uh,
I hate to say this,
you look at a country like Pakistan that
I was just going to bring them up.
I mean if Pakistan didn't have nuclear
weapons,
we would not
really be all that interested in
Pakistan,
a sketchy place.
And you know,
Shane Smith was telling me about Jane
Smith,
the head of vice was telling me,
but what does that one city in Pakistan
that he was talking about that he said
is essentially the most dangerous spot
on earth.
He's like,
there are so many murders created in the
city.
Then you can [inaudible] you was,
he told them.
I think that's exactly what it was.
It was just saying it's an insanely
dangerous murderous place.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's A.
Although there are parts of Pakistan
that have beautiful.
Yeah.
And parts of Elo hell are probably nice
to a nice spot outside of the lava side
for the lava.
Um,
but it's.
Yeah.
So I think it's those,
it's those places like Pakistan that
really have Iran.
They continue their march.
This idea that somehow that at agreement
stop them from developing that,
you know,
even though even the previous
administration couldn't keep that,
you know,
she'll up any.
Are you worried about Iran?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
In the sense that,
um,
again they're continuing their,
they're testing their ballistic systems.
They're obviously,
I think they're still continuing
spinning centrifuges and we don't know
about it.
They've got a lot of hot women though.
They.
Yeah.
Well there is at so that.
Yeah,
it was hot Persian broads to come over
here.
Man.
Persians.
Yeah.
There's some other bodies like the,
they,
they make them good.
Yeah.
Well,
stout genetics.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it,
it is.
Yeah,
It's,
it's how do,
how do you account for that?
You're a dangerous nuclear power,
but you've got these really hot women so
we have put the two of them together and
make something happen.
Yeah,
no.
There was something like Bill Clinton
make it happen.
There was something that was going on.
We're a.
trump was really like openly criticized
for saying that he wants to put America
first.
You know,
I thought that was so strange and people
were saying it like it was one of the
most horrible things a president has
ever said ever.
I got so confused by that.
I'm like,
isn't that what every country says all
over the world?
So you want them to put America second
somewhere in the top five?
Yeah.
Sixth.
Is that like really being a altruistic,
like what does that mean by someone
being upset that he wants to put America
first?
I mean,
if,
if there's bad treaties,
if there's bad agreements,
if there's,
if there's anything that doesn't favor
us or our economy or our safety,
why wouldn't you want them to put
America first?
That's really weird.
Here's where I think we are with that.
Maybe I'm completely wrong on this
theory,
but if Donald Trump was any other
ethnicity been saying,
America first would not be construed as
racist.
I think people,
I think the far left construes it is
racist because he's a white guy,
right?
So everything through race,
they view everything through race.
As far as I'm concerned.
You think of Obama said that they would
think he's being conciliatory to the
ride and you know,
that he's like trying to drum up paper
patriotism or say look at he's trying to
fire up the economy.
It's all about jobs.
I just don't think it would be,
you know,
I just don't think it would have the
same impact.
And I think if Hillary Clinton said it,
I think she would get a pass,
but I think you're right there.
So you know,
some crazy shit about Russia that we
should be able to respond militarily to
the cyber attacks.
I was like,
you really can't say shit like that.
And apparently what was sad was that
they had said to the Russian people they
were in contact with,
look,
this is all just rhetoric to worry about
it,
but yeah,
that's what I was reading.
I don't know if that's really how it
goes down.
No,
it's,
it's pretty crazy shit when you start
trying to imagine what's that line where
another nation engages in some sort of
cyber shenanigans and we're gonna
respond militarily.
The Pentagon is still trying to figure
that out.
One guy has been working on this for
some time,
it's don't try and draw this her,
so they haven't done it either.
But the idea of what are your protocols
for,
for a cybersecurity,
for cyber attacks,
cyber warfare,
uh,
they're still trying to figure that out
because it's so freaking difficult.
But think about in this particular
instance,
what we're talking about is not really
cyber warfare.
It's someone getting a hold of some
emails.
So you read my emails,
I'm going to launch a bomb at you.
It would have to be,
I'm hoping,
I would think threshold will be higher
than that,
but it taking down infrastructure,
but if you want to look at it from a
simplistic point of view,
I mean,
that's really what they're saying.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And,
and that's where you're right,
the rhetorics got and you can't do that.
You can engage in that sort of
conversation or you know,
uh,
that's why I would like to think that
the new president would have,
you know,
or start to have more.
And I think it may be happening more
discipline and sort of the messaging
because you got to,
you can't,
you can't say shit out there anymore.
Well,
that was driving me crazy because I
would tell that to my friends who were
Hillary supporters and they,
you know,
they would try to ignore it.
I go,
how can you ignore that?
That is a fucking crazy statement if you
have my email,
so I'm going to launch the military at
you.
But it,
there's still confusion.
Even if you think about there was a
cyber attack by a nation state,
a against our electrical grid,
for instance,
took down the,
the.
There's only three grids in this
country,
east West in Texas.
So they took down the east grid.
Think of anything.
Now,
if it's a serious and coordinated in a
sophisticated attack,
you may be down for three,
four,
five,
six weeks,
seven weeks could be longer because we
don't manufacture a lot of that,
that gear for the system anymore.
Here in this country we're in,
we're putting lipstick on a pig for the
most of the patchwork quilt of the,
of the power grid.
And so it's a,
it's a fairly frail thing anyway,
but if they take that down,
then you think to yourself,
well,
how do we respond to,
we do the same to the,
the,
the attacking nation that engaged in
that.
Do we respond militarily?
And that's where the,
you know,
again,
the Pentagon,
it's been sitting there trying to figure
out how,
what do we do,
what are the protocols,
what are the responses,
what's the,
what line do we need to see before we.
So,
you know,
this is a,
it's a whole different world and this is
something to really pay attention to it.
Because going forward when talk about,
well,
you know,
maybe something happens and you get
people starting to launch nukes.
Yeah,
maybe again,
you get some crazy as a leader of a
small nation that decides to do
something or they get overrun and you
know,
it falls into bad hands,
whatever.
But more likely than not,
what's going to happen is something that
spins out of Control in cyberspace.
And because we either,
you know,
we overreact or we under react and then
we were playing catch,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Just a constant game of arbitration and
coordinated communication and trying to
soothe things out,
keep things from getting too crazy,
which is why,
again,
I sometimes make fun of diplomacy,
but diplomacy is very,
very important.
So you've got to have those
communication channels open all the
time.
People have to be talking,
you know,
the,
Intel services talk to each other all
the time.
Even when you know two countries or even
when us in another country going at it
in the media,
you know,
or we're really,
yeah,
the Intel services tend to be at working
together,
keeping that line of communication
because they know it's pretty serious
shit.
You got to do that and things can get
sideways really,
really fast out there.
And so,
you know,
you got to hope that the,
the conversations continue and we've got
good people.
I look at the new administration sort of
second and third tier folks,
you know,
were crap actually gets done,
not the cabinet level or anything but
the down second,
third tier.
And they brought in some,
some good pragmatic people.
They've got some smart folks.
They understand.
I think the way the world works,
they're measured in their response.
Now,
does any of that matter?
You know,
because the president is,
you know,
can be,
Tommy Lewis County.
Yeah.
He's his own guy and all he's gonna make
his own decision or if you're like,
who knows,
I,
you know,
you know this,
this caught everybody by surprise.
So didn't really.
No one saw it coming.
Maybe there were a handful of people.
I think there were four,
four people in the entire country.
Uh,
but yeah,
I mean,
anybody else who said,
yeah,
I knew this was going to happen.
They're just blowing smoke up your ass.
I don't think there were very small
number of people.
I guess that actually saw it.
This was developing and what's going to
happen now.
I had friends that jumped on the trump
train early,
really early back in when you thought,
wow,
you're what you're doing what?
Um,
but I think,
you know,
did they see something or were they just
looking for a campaign they could ride?
I don't know.
You know,
that is part of the problem.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Everybody's looking for a job in,
in,
in a sense.
Well,
there's also,
I don't know if you've noticed this
online,
but there's a bunch of weird sort of now
now very obvious right wing guys,
but people that were just sort of a
online commentators or they would have a
blog or a little of this or that,
and then when it kind of became a
movement,
this trump thing became a movement.
All of their stuff got really pro trump
and they started using words like cock
column,
People Cox and like and fallen into
this,
these camps where you're just seeing
these tribal sort of behavior patterns
play out.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
absolutely.
And some of that is because you know,
you again,
you've got people that are thinking,
okay,
look,
this could actually happen.
Would like a job.
I'd like to be on the winning side.
I like to jump on the team.
I'd like to be one of the people
considered as an ally instead of an
enemy.
And I find that that's the way the game
works.
I guess our though it's bizarre to
watch.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
uh,
early on I signed onto a national
security letter with some other folks,
basically said that,
you know,
we didn't believe that a Donald Trump,
now president trump,
uh,
was the right candidate for,
from a national security perspective.
Right.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
I took some heat for that,
um,
but some of those folks are now looking
for jobs in the administration and I
think,
I don't get it,
what did you.
But I will say this much,
I once,
you know,
once the person wins,
and this is maybe where,
you know,
I,
I have a hard time understanding some of
the angst that's out there.
Once the president gets in,
you've got a duty to,
you know,
work and make the country,
go forward and work.
And so I've got no problem supporting
the administration in the sense that I
want them to do well.
And I don't think there's anything in
Congress with that and in the sense that
I,
yeah,
it wasn't my candidate,
you know,
I'm fine,
but now that he's in,
I want this place to do well and so I
want this administration to do well.
I'm,
I'm glad that they've got good people
coming in.
Um,
but you know,
I still say there's gonna be things and
he's going to do that.
I'm going to say,
yeah,
it's great,
good,
excellent.
And there's going to be things he
doesn't know.
What the hell is that?
And I,
you know,
if you can't be in that position and
you've always got to be all onboard or
all against,
I don't see how people live
that way and that's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
Do you think it's possible that he could
pull this off and he could be a good
president and he could listen to the
advice of the people that actually know
how the world works and stay off
twitter?
I don't think it's possible to stay off
twitter.
I don't think it's,
it's like that old scorpion right on the
back of the tweets with sad anymore.
Sad.
He can't say that anymore.
It's got to stop that.
I can't just say sad.
I don't think that shit's going to end.
But could you surprise people?
Could good things happen as a result of
a change in administrations?
Uh,
could the economy,
you know,
it gets see a bump.
Could we?
Yeah,
sure.
Of course.
I hope it happens.
I really do hope it happens.
I'm really whole.
P really does commit to rebuilding the
infrastructure,
you know,
that's what I think could get a lot of
great jobs and would do a lot of good
for us.
Yeah,
I know,
I agree.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
Roads,
bridges,
pipes,
water pipes.
Um,
I think that there's,
and I,
if he goes in that direction,
if we see that now again,
you got people questioning that,
you know,
sort of the spending.
Um,
so,
you know,
the jury's out on and um,
what they do with taxes,
it seems like they're going to go in a
decent direction on the,
on the taxes.
But yeah,
I,
I think it could.
I think it could surprise people because
I think what are missing is they see
chaos.
I see a lot of chaos,
but you could also argue it's,
it's actually a beneficial thing to have
a lot of people talking at you,
taking a light because they do seem
willing to listen to a lot of different
people.
Right?
At least early stage.
I realized I could change or maybe you
know,
and I don't wanna make too much of it,
but they do seem like there's a lot of
different voices that are being dragged
in and saying,
what do you think about this?
What do you think about that?
Now he's going to make his own decision,
but we get lost.
We don't see those things happen.
You know,
it's like the discussions that they've
already started about how do we re,
uh,
align the Intel community so that it's
more efficient,
more effective.
That's a good conversation to have.
But we don't see that because people get
lost in the tweets and they get lost in,
you know,
the various headline of the day,
the cult of personality.
And there is.
And there is,
to be fair,
there's a media out there that wants him
to fail as soon as possible.
I mean they were just hoping that he
wants to think that is because he's
criticizing them because he's openly
going into the war with them.
Sure.
I guess that's it.
And also,
you know what I mean.
Let's be fair.
This is not,
I'm not saying anything that people are
going to be shocked by,
but you know,
that this was not.
Their candidate never would be the e
stands for everything they don't like.
It's a very,
you know,
a part of the media is very insular
obviously.
Again,
this is all stuff that people know so
it's no surprise,
but there's a large portion of the media
out there that really wants him to fail
and they're actively working towards
that end.
So again,
you could go back to the previous
administration and say,
well look what Fox News was there.
They were always questioning president,
you know,
that was one voice,
fine.
And some talk radio.
But Eh,
you know,
I don't know.
So I think,
I think there's a good chance,
a good chance there's a chance that the
president could turn out to be a lot
better.
Uh,
there's probably a good chance it'll
turn out to be better than people
thought.
Um,
and you know,
I,
you would like to think that everybody
would want that to happen,
you know,
who sits around and hopes it.
Obviously.
Again,
there were people on the right that
wanted Obama to fail.
Okay.
I,
that course again,
but it's what we're talking about before
when you said,
you know,
sort of the zealots on each side,
I don't understand that mentality.
So it's around.
I says,
I hope this guy fucks up really because
you're living here,
right?
So,
and this is your country and you got
kids and you just want to say,
I told you so.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They want the other side to fuck up.
They want the other team,
but you know,
that's the problem is they're looking at
as the other team instead of looking at
as one big team.
Once it gets in.
I mean,
we're supposed to be all on the same
side.
Once a guy gets in,
you might criticize his movements,
you might criticize his decisions,
but ultimately you should want him to do
well because it will be good for the
entire country and you can disagree on
policy is fine,
but you know,
if you disagree then find,
get out there and do something
constructive about it.
Right.
I mean a donate or oh,
you know,
working uh,
some sort of volunteer position or you
know,
canvass your neighborhood.
Do you know the political thing?
I mean people made a lot of fun of the
tea party,
but look,
the tea party did what you're supposed
to do in a democratic society.
They organized,
they know politics,
they worked,
they canvassed,
they got representatives elected and,
and you know,
they pushed their agenda in a proper
manner.
So fuck it.
Maybe there,
maybe the far left or get over.
It's butthurt and they'll actually start
doing that shit.
But yeah,
hopefully,
hopefully it just leads to more
discussion,
more debate,
more communication and more people
having a better understanding of how the
system works.
I think if one thing that we can look
forward to with trump is that he's so
transparent and if something pisses him
off,
he's immediately going to talk about it,
that we're going to get to see more and
understand more about it,
how it works behind the scenes.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's right.
And I think that's one of those things
that people look at and you know,
unless they hate them,
they look at that as a positive and they
think,
you know what,
I'm Api that he's out there tweeting
[inaudible] I want them to bypass the
media and tell me what's going on and
all that sort of thing.
And so,
and I think he genuinely believes that
that was a big a part of why he got
elected.
So he's not going to change that shit.
Why would or.
Yeah.
So love it.
Get crazy when look,
everybody looks at someone who's in
power,
whether they're the president or
whatever it is.
They look at them as being some
irreproachable.
Some,
some person have like much higher moral
cloth and value and an intellect and we
see him.
He's clearly not right,
right.
You know,
it gets mad with he such shit.
Not Rosie O'donnell.
He goes after people and you go,
this guy's like,
he's nuts.
No,
that's right.
And that's what.
And that drives the media crazy.
It drives,
it drives the academics and others on
the that have typically occupied the far
left,
fragile,
crazy cause he does look,
you know,
prime minister.
Yeah.
I've got a very progressive liberal
friends who,
you know,
that's the first thing they say is such
an idiot.
He's,
he's so stupid.
And he appeals to all the stupid people
out there.
And I said,
you know what,
you know,
how do you think you ended up with
president trump by spending eight years
telling people how stupid they are.
Right.
And,
and,
and minimizing their importance and
making fun of them.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
there you go.
Congratulations.
It's
definitely a part of it.
I mean,
he played off of that really
brilliantly.
He's a very smart persuader in that
regard.
You know,
Scott Adams,
who is the creator of Dilbert,
who predicted this whole thing a long
time in advance and took a big hit for
it,
told me it cost them millions of
dollars.
People boycotting him,
hating him,
and by the way,
he doesn't even vote because he's not
voting for trump.
He says,
I don't want to have a dog in the war.
He was like,
I don't want to have a dog in the fight.
He goes,
I feel like it's.
I can be objective about it if I don't
talk about it or if I don't vote.
So he's not voting.
He didn't vote for trump.
He didn't vote for anybody,
and he said,
what he thinks is that trump is an
excellent persuader.
He's like,
he's,
he's.
His powers of persuasion are amazing.
Yeah.
And he goes into the way he understands
how to manipulate the press and say
outrageous things.
So they talk about him constantly.
So he gets free press.
I mean,
what he did in that sense,
Scott was totally right and he was like,
Scott was looking at it completely
objective.
Lee,
he's not a trump supporter and many
people accused them of being so,
and that's why he got took so much heat
about.
He's like,
he's going
to be president,
and they're like,
you're a piece of shit,
and they hated him because of it.
It's really fascinating because when you
get to know Scott,
you realize he's a brilliant guy,
but he's unafraid to discuss what he
actually believes will take place
regardless of whether or not people
think that's what they want or what am I
smart.
I mean it's.
I didn't know that about them to really
enter the podcast I had with him as a
really entertaining.
If you ever want to listen to.
Yeah,
no,
definitely.
Definitely.
That's really interesting.
I'm like everybody else.
I got a few of his cartoons clipped out
and stuck up on my cubicle online.
I don't have a cubicle.
Probably Office bunker in a basement so
she could rollerblade in.
Dick Cheney was a in the bunker.
Yeah.
Where's the.
Where's the bunker?
I can't,
I can't.
I can't tell you what.
Tell me where it is.
It's a real thing.
A real bunker.
Yeah.
Oh,
how did he go in there?
And she's out there running around the
surface playing golf,
continually pushed out bass fishing and
shit.
Like,
hi all bass fishing death 11.
He was doing everything man.
He's out there and drink a beer on the
dock.
Cheney's seven miles underground with no
qualifications.
Tell Dick he's going to need to stay
down there.
It's still bad out here.
Why did he,
why did he go into the bunker?
Continuity of government.
So in case they killed Bush,
right?
Be Tucked away.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I mean it's the same reason why you
don't let everybody stand on the
inauguration stand during the
inauguration.
Right?
Right,
right,
right.
Randomly choose somebody as the
designated survivor.
Well,
whenever they start talking about how
security so locked down,
I remember that guy who was the sign
language interpreter for Obama.
It turned out to be a complete
psychopath who didn't know sign language
at all and he was up there just making
fucking signs and shut tastic.
And this guy was standing three feet
away from the fucking president.
Nobody vetted him.
Nobody.
Nobody fucking did anything.
There've been a few security screw ups.
There was a little while back before
that incident that you're talking about
the guy.
Yeah.
The guy in the elevator,
which was an.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
Yeah,
yeah,
we talked about that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was,
it was a great to a great story.
Not,
not great in the sense that it was a,
it was a fuck up,
but at the same time it was fascinating.
So,
uh,
it was,
at CDC,
he went down,
he went down to Atlanta.
That was right.
And he got onto the president.
Sorry,
the president got on the elevator and
uh,
he had his detail with them obviously,
and this one fellow went to get on the
elevator and who does that?
Who even thinks that the presenter,
I'm going to keep the door open.
I got to get on,
I got to Texas,
or Ah,
I got my lunch,
I got to get to my desk.
And so it gets on the secret service.
Asked him to leave obviously.
First of all,
he shouldn't have been on there.
They should have had,
you know,
a couple of guys standing outside the
door.
He asked him to leave.
He won't,
he won't leave.
They rides up basically.
And then as it turns out,
he's armed and he's a guard.
Right.
He said private security guard for that
facility on,
under contract with a company that had
the contract for security.
It was armed.
They didn't even know it.
So server that.
No idea.
Yeah.
He's got a standing in an elevator and
he's in the elevator three feet away
from the process.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
So there,
there've been little situations like
that.
It's a tough,
tough job,
but you know,
that secret service operation.
I know,
it seems like it only makes the news
when there's some bad thing that
happened to fuck up or something.
People find funny,
like,
you know,
some hookers or whatever,
but uh,
it's a,
it's a tough ass job.
Oh,
I can only imagine.
And we should applaud them.
How few of those fuck ups ever had.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
And you know,
they,
they do.
It's a,
it's kind of a thankless job in,
in many,
many ways.
And it's,
it's just really a,
it's always high stress.
It's always stressed.
And so I,
yeah,
I,
I give those folks a lot of credit,
just like the FBI,
FBI has staff with brilliant people,
great people.
Which just imagine this woman who made
this facebook post about not being
willing to take a bullet for the
president.
What if she said that about the CEO of
allstate?
Right?
You'd be like a good move.
Don't take a bullet.
Like that's how crazy the job is.
That there is a consideration that she
might one day have to take a bullet for
the president.
Yeah.
And apparently she wasn't.
Okay.
Very good.
Yeah.
Maybe she was just angry and maybe she
didn't do her job because she's a
patriot.
Yeah.
Hopefully.
So that would be nice.
But I think she's gonna at least be on
ice for a while based on that.
But,
uh,
yeah,
you know,
it's,
uh,
and that's true of any executive
protection detail.
Uh,
obviously it's,
it's a heightened situation when you're
talking about the president or you know,
us,
dignitaries or whatever,
but anybody in that business,
there's no room for ego.
Can't have an ego if your body guards to
make people think about bodyguards and
they tend to think about somebody who's
a,
you know,
protecting,
the Kardashians or something,
you know,
it's not a celebrity bodyguard,
but the executive protection world is a
fairly large business and you know,
it's,
it's a really tough industry and there's
no room for egos and it's a,
requires a real variety of skills,
diplomacy,
common sense on top of all the typical
skills you would imagine.
And it is,
again,
it's just a sort of a thankless job.
You know,
you're often dealing with principals who
really don't even want you there.
You know,
high net wealth families.
I net wealth individuals and they just
needed a tolerant.
They tolerate it.
They don't really want you there and,
or they,
you know,
they think you're after awhile you're
just there to carry bags.
And so the folks that do those jobs,
you know,
in serious details,
it's really tough.
And then like out out in Hollywood,
you know,
you sometimes get down,
the bodyguard is,
you know,
they,
they all hire whoever happens to be
biggest and that's the worst thing,
you know,
you don't want it some,
some big thick neck guy out there
thinking that he's going to protect you
and that he's the best guy when it could
in fact be the five foot two woman who's
going to be actually the smartest
because she's got all the right skills.
She's got the other,
you know,
and if you've got something busted up on
top of the principal,
you've already fucked up,
right?
You've already missed the opportunity
to,
to sort the problem out.
So,
right,
sometimes it's better with a physically
vulnerable person because they take
steps to make sure that it never gets to
that point.
Whereas the big guy thinks he can handle
it,
always looks to handle it or,
or,
you know.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
you know,
again,
how much are we are we veered off into
that conversation.
But it's a,
it's a fascinating world.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's again heightened when you're
talking about the president.
Um,
so beyond.
Yeah.
How do you feel about
w w,
w,
what do you think?
Like we should we be concerned about
Putin and Russia?
I mean,
is that something we need to go back to
when I grew up?
I mean,
you and I are pretty much the same age
when we're in high school.
You remember that fear,
like everybody had this fear hanging
over our head that we were going to go
to war with Russia is going to be a
mutually assured destruction.
Nuclear War.
There was nothing we could do.
I used to go to bed.
Sometimes they think about that when I
was like 14.
I'd be like,
fuck,
I don't want to die in a nuclear bomb.
Exactly.
No,
I 100 percent.
I mean,
I remember when in elementary school,
uh,
you know,
we'd have a duck and cover under your
desk.
Good luck with all that.
I remember one of my,
one of my friends,
once I was sitting under the desk and
mark said,
we started talking.
I looked at him and I had older
brothers,
you know,
so they'd already told me that help
bullshit that exercise was.
But I realized that my friend Mark Air
sitting there as we kind of ate our
lunch underneath a desk,
what seemed like this was going to do
it,
this was going to protect us.
And I remember looking at him and I told
him,
I said,
mark,
this is not going to stop a nuclear
bomb.
There's no way that thing's going to
just blow the shit out of us.
And he was like,
oh my God,
I think I ruined the kid for,
for life.
But he got to work in the CIA.
And this poor dudes still shaken into
God to protect their duties.
Uh,
so anyway,
uh,
no,
I think we should be worried about
puente in the sense that he,
his agenda,
his interest don't match up with ours.
Um,
we should be worried in the sense that
he honestly believes that the biggest
catastrophe was the collapse of the
Soviet Union.
Uh,
and he's never believed.
He's never believed that there was a
peace dividend from the,
the,
the end of the Cold War.
Never ever thought that way.
And we did.
And there was talk about up on capital
hill after the end of the Cold War,
that fall of the Berlin Wall,
we could shut down the CIA,
what do we need that for anymore?
And that was a same thought that
happened after World War Two.
World War Two ended and Harry Truman
signed an order that ended,
uh,
the office of strategic services,
which was the precursor for the CIA,
shut it down,
took two years,
two years while the,
the Soviet Union started building up and
rampaging for,
uh,
the president of thank you know,
maybe this is actually a good idea.
So then he created the CIA at that
point.
Uh,
but,
you know,
we,
we thought we were going to get some
sort of dividend out of the end of that
and it just wasn't gonna happen.
The Russians never ever believed that
Putin and particular in his,
his cohorts never thought that was the
case.
So yeah,
we should be concerned about Russia.
They're not going to ever be,
it's not going to be a bipolar world
again,
where there the other major superpower,
but um,
in the sense that we need to deal with
him realistically,
we should always talk fine,
let's do a diplomacy,
but we just need to be pragmatic and
understand.
Look,
we're not going to.
Our interests aren't the same and if as
long as we keep that in mind as sure I
talk all we want to them.
Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy.
He's a physicist.
What he did by,
you know,
running Russia,
stepping back and being sort of a puppet
master for awhile and then jumping back
in 2012 and running it again.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
you know,
that's the type of behavior that people
are terrified of when someone is just
sort of a blatant dictator but masked as
a democracy.
Right.
And he's like,
he doesn't even really try the masking.
Not Anymore.
After 2012 we just kind of ramped it up.
Yeah.
He's,
he's done in part.
And I what I said that he thinks it was
a catastrophe.
That's,
those are his words.
He thought he said the collapse of the
Soviet Union was the greatest
catastrophe of the 20th century and he's
absolutely serious about it.
So he's been trying to rebuild that in
some fashion or another ever since then.
And it's not just territory,
although he's done a pretty good job of
that,
you know,
we forget that before Crimea,
um,
you know,
he rolled troops into Georgia,
right?
Not,
not,
not the state of Georgia Thinking,
oh my God,
no,
that doesn't make sense.
I don't think Mike knows what he's
talking about.
Um,
so,
but in Georgia,
the Republic of Georgia,
and uh,
I'll be damned,
but he's still got troops there.
He's got a lot of troops are and it's in
a upc.
Kazia and south assess you.
And then he's also obviously took Crimea
and why to take Crimea.
Well,
because it's important to his fleet.
It's not gonna.
It's not gonna happen.
He's not going to risk losing that.
And then,
you know,
part of the Ukraine and,
but it's not just territory that he's
interested in.
It's leverage,
its influence.
And that's where,
when we go back to that conversation
about the Middle East and we realized
what they'd been doing in the Middle
East in particular,
they've been active in other places,
but mostly in the Middle East.
Uh,
that's all part of this same process,
this and it's so,
it's not a mystery why he does things.
It's if you,
if you take him at his base word,
which we should do because he's,
he,
he tends to say exactly what he intends
to do most of the time.
Um,
and not try to read our values into it,
right?
Not Say,
well,
I'm sure he doesn't mean that.
I'm sure what he means is like,
you know,
he's,
he,
he wants to get to democracy eventually,
but that's a lot of horseshit.
But we tend to mirror our values on
other people.
Right?
So when we were talking about earlier
about how,
you know,
there's not another nation out there
that really kind of approaches global
concerns a way that we do with certain
set of principles and,
and desires,
even if we make mistakes.
And obviously we do from time to time,
of course.
Um,
then,
you know,
you look at,
you look at Russia and you think that,
you know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't do that.
He doesn't look at something and go,
hmm,
maybe that would be best for all of us.
I don't think he's ever had that
thought,
you know,
he,
he literally is single minded in his
desire to do whatever.
We'll build back up Russian influence in
the world.
So we have to be pragmatic about it and
dealing with them
and to get a better understanding of
him.
Um,
I think,
uh,
there's a great podcast between Sam
Harris and Gary Kasparov,
the chess champion who was a big critic
of Putin has managed to stay alive
somehow or another q and a,
I guess because he's just so famous.
But that was a thing with one of his
political opponents.
He thought that if he was public he
would be much less likely to be killed.
And they shot him right in front of his
fucking girlfriend and public.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's it.
There've been a number of incidences,
bunch bunch of those.
I mean,
he's a on a totally different level,
but Kasparov highlights the fact that
he's a former kgb agent and says like,
you have to understand the mentality of
the KGB,
like once you are kgb,
your kgb for life.
I mean,
it was an extreme form of nationalism
and patriotism and this,
this loyalty to the KGB that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
He's eight and he's absolutely right.
There's no,
he's not going to change.
But again,
we,
we do this thing where we,
you know,
it's basically called mirroring,
right?
I mean it's like I,
and so you know,
and we and we,
and then we get tripped up and we think
you could look at Iraq and Afghanistan
as an example.
Of course they're going to love this.
You gotTa love democracy.
And because we love it,
we want to do well.
We want to improve their literacy rate
and we want to do these things well
that's all great stuff,
but it doesn't work in the sense that
that's not how they view things.
You know,
cars.
I looked at that.
That is a shitload of money that I'm
gonna be able to steal here.
Cars I family was completely corrupt and
remember there was that period of time
when we just adored him.
We were,
it was adulation.
You know,
how,
how wonderful his cars I look out.
Well,
he dresses and that was boring.
What the hell?
So yeah.
So Putin,
I think again,
not in a sense that we've got some world
war three coming up against Russia.
That's not the case.
That's not why we should be concerned
about them.
Although you do have to,
you know,
again,
worry about military buildup,
worry about their,
uh,
a nuke program,
you know,
and,
and what they're doing with their ears
and what we're doing with ours.
A unilateral disarmament.
Not a good idea.
You know,
whether we're talking about Putin or
anybody else,
um,
you can always want peace and you can
strive for peace.
But I have not seen a world that works
differently.
You've got to do that through a position
of strength.
I think these conversations are so
important because when a guy like you
talks about this,
you're not talking out of your ass and
you get a chance to understand how crazy
the situation is worldwide and how
difficult it is and what a balancing act
it is.
Yeah.
It is.
And,
and you know,
and it's tough.
I wouldn't want to be like the head of
the State Department.
I mean the chief diplomat,
it's a tough ass job.
You don't get any sleep now,
but you've got to do it and you got to
keep that level.
It's just like fighting terrorism.
It's like fighting Islamic state.
You've got do it on several different
levels.
Community outreach and you know,
they're trying to solve problems here,
doing it militarily.
All these things have to work together
and we got to be smart enough to do
that.
So the same thing with,
with dealing with Russia.
Yeah.
Well you know,
but the narrative that somehow trump was
being played by Putin was his best
friend was until I don't,
I'm not buying any of that shit.
I think what we'll find is you need to
watch more.
Keith overman video.
Yeah.
Oh,
right.
No,
I know.
Who Doesn't love Keith Olbermann silent.
Cool.
I think what we're going to find is,
is,
uh,
is uh,
what trump probably I think maybe again,
who knows?
Maybe please pop it.
Um,
I think what,
what he's thinking is,
you know,
what we need to,
as an example of the military will get
to build up the military.
Well,
he knows that,
you know,
he's smart enough to understand that,
we got that a wall to fall because we
outspent the hell out of the Russians.
Right.
We,
and also part of it was Reagan.
They actually didn't know if Reagan was
crazy enough to hit the button.
Right.
And so that,
unknowing,
that uncertainty about what Reagan was
all about combined with the fact that
we,
we were outspending them,
um,
and they couldn't keep up.
That's what brought the Soviets
eventually to realize,
yeah,
this is,
you know,
we've got to realign things because this
isn't going to work.
As soon as they found out that Nancy
Reagan based all of our decisions and
all advice on astrology,
yeah,
they're probably like,
wait,
what?
Yeah,
hold on.
Let's get them on the phone.
We're going to need to talk.
This was real.
She being serious.
Astrology.
Yeah.
What was that?
Astrologers name was gene.
Something sounded that.
Yeah.
Find out what the Nancy Reagan Bill
Clinton again.
I can.
I never get tired of looking at.
My favorite thing is his look to to
fucking Hillary.
Don't look at me.
Yeah.
Just growing out of it.
That white man bite,
he gets almost all his hips starting to
make it.
His sister of Nancy Reagan,
astrologer.
Joan Quigley.
Nancy listened religiously to what Joan
had to say.
Wow.
Joan Quigley.
Huh?
Even the flight schedule or a forest
one.
Wow.
That's news to right now how big it is
right now,
but this is a trump
trump signs order to bar some refugees
signaling.
Prioritizing Syrian Christians letting
Syrian Christians through.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Have a priority.
How do you know that they're going to be
fucking Syrian Christian?
How do you know they're really
Christian?
They're going to have priority probably
be wearing a cross.
Oh,
well that's.
That's.
That sounds crazy.
Identifying specific countries with
Muslim majorities and carving out
exceptions for minority religions flies
in the face of the constitutional
principle that bands of government from
either favoring or discriminating
against particular religions.
Ramiro said,
this is the trump card.
Okay,
if you were a Muslim,
you could come in,
but if you were a Christian,
it's almost impossible and the reason
that that was so unfair,
everybody was persecuted in all
fairness,
but they were chopping off the heads of
everybody,
but more so the Christian tell is,
is the president.
He says,
crazy.
You know I,
I believe that's a run on sentence.
Might be a little bit of a run on trump
said in an excerpt of an interview with
the Christian Broadcasting Network.
Oh,
thank God he's talking to them.
Is a Jim Baker still on that?
Jim Baker selling food scene.
Jim Baker.
That video.
Let's,
let's,
let's end with this because this is a
jim and Tammy Faye Bakker.
Tammy Faye died from diet coke.
Diet coke gave Tammy Faye brain cancer
and she died.
She,
she's strict jugs of diet coke every day
and she got,
got the cancer.
So,
uh,
I don't like when people say the byway
diet coke,
I'm just fucking around.
I don't really think,
don't send me.
I don't really think she got cancer from
that.
She probably got cancer from Jim Baker's
dirty Dick,
Coca Cola Company for trout.
We tried televangelists,
Jim Baker,
survival food.
He sells survival food and he sells it
as a potential a base for your table.
What he wants you to do is take these
buckets.
They pulled that video down away.
Okay.
So it's like the walls of water breaks.
Yeah.
Well he sells these buckets of food.
They must've pulled it.
They must have had them pull it.
What was the guy's name that was running
that,
that runs that Youtube Channel?
Let's give him his proper video is gone.
So it doesn't say the channel.
What's the.
Oh his channel's gone.
Another.
The channels not.
But it doesn't say who the sad face
there.
Quick search to try to find that dude's
name.
Cause he's got a bunch of really
hilarious videos,
but he made a compilation of all the
wackiest moments.
I'm Jim Baker show where he tries to
sell the survival food and he's got like
this table that he sets down instead of
on like legs.
It's set down on these buckets of
survival food that he recommends.
This is where you store your survival
food.
You use it as the base of your table.
Midcentury modern look stupid because
you can't get your feet under the table.
Then here it is.
Oh,
what's the dude's name?
Vic Berger.
Vic Berger Presents Jim Baker's buckets.
So He's,
he starts,
uh,
this is Jim Baker's what he looks like
now.
He's got himself a new Tammy Faye.
And so he's got all those buckets of
food behind him.
That's him right there.
And that's his new gal.
I could not have picked him out of a
lineup and look at it.
So this is buckets of food that he's
selling.
He's hilarious.
And to the right,
what does that buckets of milk new bulk
sampler bundle?
Twenty 3,375
servings.
Only 2000,
$500 by the way.
That's really a bargain.
And half of that goes to Jesus and look,
it's got.
He's got a shovel with this.
Why do you have a shovel?
Well,
for Aiden,
I guess cook on that shovel.
I'll get those two guys.
Jesus Christ man.
Scoop in that bulk sampler bundle.
Reaching in and eaten it.
What the fuck is he eating?
So why is he doing the.
If you could just eat it with his hand.
This.
He's an animal.
So that's how he eats pussy to.
Gets right in there.
Just picks them up by the ass.
Now obviously Bill Clinton one more
time.
Yeah,
let's end on the bill.
You had to end up with Alex Super App.
That's like curry looks very appetizing.
Psycho,
wonderful butterscotch pudding type of.
And who doesn't want it?
There's an apocalypse who doesn't want
to just have buckets of putting in line
around.
Yeah.
So that's what the shovels for.
Jesus Christ.
He is going to have diarrhea like
nobody's business as soon as commercial.
So she's.
Oh,
she uses a scenario,
Tammy Faye.
A powerful good times.
So let's,
uh,
let's put,
put,
pull up that Ivanka video one more time.
We'll watch this one.
We'll send you off into the bit.
You want to give a plug to your security
company.
You know,
I always,
always happy to mention that diligence
for all your intelligence and security
risk mitigation needs work with
operations and stuff.
Here it is.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Good job.
Good job of Funko.
Fight in that lower lip.
So I think if you just started,
we just started gyrating.
Here it comes here,
comes to the look.
Fantastic.
She's just glaring error.
It is.
He took a look at her face.
Oh Nah,
she nods and she's fucking burning on
bad luck.
Oh,
she's so pretty though.
So looks like a young Tracy Lord.
On that note.
No gentleman.
Mike Baker.
Uh,
Joseph.
Thank you brother.
Thanks for coming back and falls apart.
We'll see you in six months.
At least explain to us what happened,
what went wrong.
I will.
I'll do it.
You got my word.
All right folks,
that's it.
We will be back on Sunday.
So we're not going to be here for the
fight companion on Saturday,
but we're going to play the fights and
not watch them.
So I'm not watching them on Saturday
night.
I'm going to record them here and then
we're going to come in on Sunday and
it's going to be branded shop.
Eddie Bravo,
Brian Cowen,
and my pal Jimmy Burke.
It's going to be a good God damn time
folks.
So if you want to get in with us Sunday
7:00
PM Pacific,
don't watch the fights before then.
We'll have it on record.
Will probably fast forward through the
commercials.
I don't know how we're going to do that.
We'll figure it out.
See you soon.
Bye.
Mm.